Herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos Nummer 6.
Genau, schon Folge 6. Und wir waren doch recht begeistert von der Resonanz auf die letzte Folge, die Nummer 5, die sich um Schluxner drehte.
Die Spezialfolge.
Die Spezialfolge. Und wir wollten dieses Mal eigentlich keine Themenfolge machen, sind aber darauf gekommen, dass wir doch zwei Themen haben, über die wir mal reden müssen. Das erste Thema ist Stuttgart 21, insbesondere da die ganze Sache mit der Polizeigewalt und wie eigentlich die Polizeigewalt funktioniert und warum. Und die zweite Sache ist die Debatte um die Netzneutralität, die Fefe sehr am Herzen liegt und wozu er mal ein paar Dinge sagen muss. Und weil wir mal ein paar Dinge sagen müssen, dafür gibt es ja diesen Podcast hier, also machen wir das jetzt auch. Wir wollten erstmal Danke sagen für die vielen Flatters. Wir sparen gerade mit den Flatters so ein wenig auf ein neues Aufnahme-Equipment. Momentan haben wir so einen alten Zoom H4 und wollten dann nach und nach mal upgraden auf ein Setup, mit dem wir auch noch Gäste dazunehmen können, also mit dem wir bis zu vier Leute hier sitzen und reden können. Das wäre jetzt mal so unser nächstes Sparziel, wenn ihr wollt, dass wir schneller Gäste dazuholen können, dann erflattert mal ein bisschen mehr. Ansonsten wollen wir euch ja nicht weiter erpressen. Ansonsten noch noch vielen Dank für die Stucknet-Sample, die wir zugesendet bekommen haben in Folge dieser letzten Folge. Die haben uns sehr erfreut. Es ist aber wieder schön, wenn unsere Hörer aufmerksam sind und uns Geschenke schenken, auch in Form von potenziell geheimdienstlich erzeugter Mailware.
Wo wir gerade bei Geheimdiensten waren... Warte mal, eine Hausmeister-Sache fällt mir noch ein. Und zwar haben wir ja letztes Mal über X.509-Zertifikate geredet und wie schwierig das ist, da den Trust zu bootstrappen. Und da haben wir uns darüber unterhalten, wie man eigentlich Trust bootstrappt und dass wir ja PGP-Keys haben zum Beispiel. Und haben uns entschieden, dass wir mal als Stunt hier unseren Fingerprint verlesen wollen. Also zumindest ich meinen.
Wo ist denn mein?
Na, es reicht ja, wenn wir einen verlesen. Genau, also ich lese mal meinen Wort. Und zwar, wer es nicht weiß, die letzten acht Ziffern eines Fingerprints sind auch gleich die Key-ID, nachdem man dann den Key-Server fragen kann. Also 8 7 8 C B E 5 D A 9 A 5 0 5 9 5 E 6 7 4 1 8 3 F 1 5 3 9 6 A 7 9 3 3 E B 0 5 9 A. Eigentlich waren wir nur ein Trend für Nummer 3.
Aber für welche Key-ID war das jetzt?
Das waren die letzten 8 Ziffern erforderlich. Die könnt ihr auch nochmal separat vorlesen. Das ist 3 3 E B 0 5 9 A.
Und das für welche Mail-Adressen?
Das ist felix.fefe.de beziehungsweise felixblockinput.fefe.de Die kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich auch alle.
Verstehe, wir müssen uns auch mal ein Key für Alternativlos zulegen, damit uns die Leute nicht nur Stuxnet-Samples schicken, sondern auch die internen Reports dazu.
Ja, das machen wir einfach zu demselben Key noch als E-Mail-Alias dazu.
Stimmt, kannst du als E-Mail-Alias dazu. Gut, meinen Key gibts dann in der nächsten Sendung.
Also eigentlich machen wir das ja, um festzustellen, wie viele Leute jetzt auch in ihren Podcasts ihre Key-Fingerprints vorlesen.
Also ich finde diese Geschichte mit den Nummernstationen großartig und eigentlich sollten wir eine Podcast-Nummernstation mit den PGP-IDs und den Fingerprints ist einfach ein guter Plan, dass werden wir jetzt fortsetzen.
Eigentlich hätten wir das subtil falsch vorlesen müssen jetzt, so als Gag.
Subtil falsch?
Um mal zu sehen, weil dann kriegst du ja Feedback, wenn es nicht passt. Um zu sehen, wie viele Leute...
Ob irgendjemand mitschreibt?
Ja! Dann mitschreiben muss man ja nicht. Okay, also nächstes Mal sagen wir subtil falsch an.
Nein, nächstes Mal müssen wir vor allen Dingen erst mal sagen, Schreibbereitschaft herstellen.
Wieso? Das ist doch Internet, da kannst du ja zurückspulen. Ja, zurückspulen. Das ist ja nicht echt das Radio.
Das sieht so aus, wenn es Live-Radio wäre. Sonst ist es doch irgendwie langweilig. Zurückspulen. Ich spülte den hier schon zurück.
Tja, nach diesen subversiven Gedanken sind wir jetzt zu Recht in Ordnung.
Ja, zum Thema Zurückspulen. Wir haben auch jede Menge zurückgespult diese Woche in Videos aus Stuttgart von der Baumrodungsaktion da am Hauptbahnhof, die durchgeführt wurde, um eine Grundwasseraufbereitungsanlage aufzumachen. Hast du dieses Video gesehen beim Thema Zurückspulen?
Das taktische Video?
Ja, wo jemand mal gezeigt hat, um was es da ging und wie grotesk...
Und was sie da alles besprüht haben, was überhaupt nichts mit ihrem Auftrag zu tun hatte.
Ja, völlig daneben.
Also das ging echt.
Also der andere ist, für uns ist halt mal, sich anzugucken, wie eigentlich es funktioniert, dass Polizei Gewalt anwendet, mit welchen technischen Hilfsmitteln und ungefähr auf welchen Rechtsgrundlagen. Wir wollen da nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen. Uns interessiert eigentlich mehr, mal ein bisschen zu erklären, wie funktioniert Polizei Gewalt eigentlich bei solchen Großlagen? Warum wird sie eingesetzt? Was kann man so ein bisschen tun, um sich dagegen zu wehren? Mich hat so ein bisschen überrascht, wie sehr überrascht die Leute davon waren, was für Verwundungen so eine Wasserwerfer verursachen.
Na und, dass die Polizei wild auf Leute einprügelt, das ist auch bei den Stuttgarter noch nicht angekommen offenbar. Vielleicht läuft immer in den Nachrichten, wenn hier in Berlin irgendwelche Leute verprügelt werden, aber da gibt es so einen psychologischen Schild, den man sich aufbaut. Ja, das sind halt Berufsdemonstranten. Das hört man ja auch jetzt bei den Pressemitteilungen der CDU. Das sind die fiesen Berufsdemonstranten, die sind eingeflogen.
Die haben mit Kastanien geschmissen.
Dann mit Pflastersteinen. Das sieht zwar aus wie Kastanien, aber eigentlich war es Pflastersteine.
Stuttgarter Pflastersteine.
Stuttgarter Kleinflaster.
Und Flaschen haben sie auch geworfen.
Also diese Geschichte mit dieser Trennung im Geiste nach guten und bösen Demonstranten ist auch so ein Ding, die mich sehr erstaunt an dieser Stuttgart-21-Geschichte. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es tatsächlich so. Also in Berlin haben wir irgendwie jedes Jahr irgendwie vier, fünf Demonstrationen oder sogar mehr, wo die Polizei sich doch einigermaßen da Leben benimmt. Es gibt noch jede Menge andere Großlagen. Dieses Jahr wird es viele davon geben. Also der Castor kommt, Calleben.
Da haben sie jetzt schon angefangen. Gab es vorgestern die Meldung, die Leute erkennungsdienstlich vorzuladen.
Vorzuladen zur erkennungsdienstlichen Behandlung. Hast du gesehen, was sie da alle haben wollten? Nicht nur Fotos von allen Seiten, auch Handkantenabdrücke.
Ja, und Gesichtsform und wiedererkennbare Verwundungen. Also unglaublich. Und am gröbsten bei diesen Briefen von der Polizei ist ja immer, dass sie sich alle Mühe geben, so zu tun, als müsste man da jetzt auch hingehen. Da ist dann so ein Absatz am Ende, da steht drin, wenn sie nicht kommen, dann holen wir sie mit Gewalt ab.
Dann kommen wir sie holen, ja.
Genau. Und das ist eine Lüge. Das ist nicht nur eine Lüge, das ist illegal, das zu sagen, weil das nämlich eine Nötigung ist. Der Staatsanwaltschaft kann euch vorladen. Und richtig kommen müsst ihr, wenn der Richter euch vorlädt. Aber die Polizei ist nur ausführendes Organ.
Also man muss auch zum Beispiel als Beschuldigter nichts sagen. Da muss man nochmal darauf hinweisen.
Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, nutzen sie es.
Nutzen sie es, genau. Interessant war ja diese Geschichte mit diesen Erfassungen. Erinnert mich sehr an diese Großproben-Nummer.
Ja, es gab gerade wieder so ein Ding, bei diesem irgendwie so ein Jugend namens marco ist irgendwie verschwunden und da haben sie dann gleich die Nummernschilder mal wieder abgefragt überall und haben die Leute irgendwie...
Nummernschilds genau aufgestellt.
Ja, und die Leute haben sich ein bisschen gewundert und haben gesagt, ja es geht um marco, na dann.
Genau.
So, also natürlich, die nutzen jeden Vorwand, den sie finden können, um alle Daten zu erheben, an die sie rankommen. Und das ist natürlich immer freiwillig. Das heißt, wenn ihr nicht meckert, dann haben die die Daten. Ja.
Und die behalten die auch.
Genau. Und wenn ihr, wenn sie euch quasi vorladen zu so einer Vermessung und ihr bewährt euch nicht, dann habt ihr den freiwillig die Daten übergeben und dann haben sie auch das Recht, die zu behalten, weil es ja freiwillig war.
Ja, also diese Datenerfassung ist ja nur eine von den Möglichkeiten, der Polizei repressiv tätig zu werden. In dem Fall sozusagen präventiv repressiv. Also mal schon vorher die Leute einschüchtern. Sie haben ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten. Also bei zum Beispiel Hooligans haben sie dann noch so vorbeugende in Gewahrsams Name und Verweisungen aus bestimmten Gegenden.
Na der Platzverweis ist natürlich der Klassiker.
Meldeauflagen gibt es übrigens auch, also dass sie dich daran hindern.
So was wie ein Fahrtenbuch nur für alles.
Nee, sie hindern dich durch die Meldeauflagen auch daran, zum Beispiel zu solchen Sachen wie Goal-Lame oder so zu fahren.
Also traditionell kommt es, glaube ich, von Fußball, Hooligans, oder?
Damit haben sie es begründet und durchgedrückt.
Also ich glaube, das ist so ein Prozess, durch den jeder mal durch muss. Man wächst irgendwie naiv auf, die Polizei ist dein Freund und Helfer. Und dann kriegt man mit, die Polizei verprügelt Leute. Und dann muss man sich das ja irgendwie mit seinem Weltbild vereinen. Und man denkt sich dann, naja, das wären halt gewaltbereite Prügel, was immer sein. Das ist ja auch die Position der Polizei. Und je mehr man dann sieht, das sind nicht unbedingt Leute, die es verdient haben, verprügelt zu werden, desto mehr muss man da durch. Und bei mir persönlich kam irgendwann der Punkt, wo ich mir gesagt habe, also diese Hooligans, die sie da immer verfolgen, vielleicht sind das gar keine Hooligans.
Die waren auch übrigens auf der Demo, ne? Also die hatte Fußballfans von da.
Auch S21, da hat der, die Fans vom Stuttgarter SV haben ein paar schöne Plakate hochgehalten. Wenn der Staat die Kinder verprügelt, irgendwie sowas, dann sieht man, wo an man ist oder so.
Können wir mal verlinken, ja.
Aber das ist ein Gedankengang, durch den man durch muss. Und ich glaube, dass ist durchaus vergleichbar mit der Situation nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, als die Leute alle gemerkt haben, als es nicht mehr zu leugnen war, was da für Dinge passiert sind. Und da muss man eben durch. Und je früher man da durch muss, desto besser.
Ja, der Ursprung von dieser Gewaltmonopol des Staates-Geschichte um die GZM-Kern ist ja eigentlich ein Guter. Also man sagt ja eigentlich, das Gewaltmonopol des Staates ist die Grundlage des Rechtsstaats. Also wenn man sagt, wenn jeder Gewalt ausüben darf, also jeder gegen jeden, dann kommen irgendwelche Leute, denen du noch Geld schuldest, dann brechen dir die Knochen oder...
Oder jemand duelliert sich mit dir.
Genau, jemand fordert dich zum Duell heraus. Und so ungefähr zu der Zeit als es aufwärte mit diesen Duellen kam diese Idee vom Gewaltmonopol des Staates dann auch so langsam in Wug. Aber es dauerte tatsächlich eigentlich bis zum, also bis nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, dass es in Deutschland zu einer effektiven Umsetzung gab. Und die eine der Begründungen für diesen, ja dieses Konzept zu sagen, nur der Staat, ist im Regelfall dazu berechtigt, Gewalt gegen Bürger auszuüben, kommt ja aus der Wärmerer Republik, wo es ja so war, dass irgendwann am Ende sich die Nazis und die Kommunisten und zwischendrin die Polizei, die sich mal auf diese und mal auf jene Seite geschlagen hat, geprügelt haben. Also meistens haben sich dann irgendwie alle gegen die Kommunisten oder auch mal die Kommunisten mit den Nazis zusammen gegen den Staat. Oder da gab es alle Kombinationen. Und es führte halt zu einer Situation, die halt nicht mehr haltbar war. So weit einfach die öffentliche Sicherheit in einer Art und Weise beschädigt war, dass niemand sich seiner Haut mehr sicher sein konnte in bestimmten Gegenden. Und deswegen wurde nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg dann dieses Gewaltmonopol des Staates institutionalisiert. Und als abstraktes Konzept klingt das ja erst mal total toll und wie eine Sache, die man eigentlich gerne haben möchte. Nur ist denn dieses Gewaltmonopol dann gerne so ein bisschen ausgeweitet worden zu diesem schönen Stichwort vom wehrhaften Staat, der sich also gegen alles Mögliche wehren muss, was irgendwie jemand in die Haut will. Und nach und nach sind halt immer mehr Kontrollinstanzen weggefallen. Also der, wo wir halt so ein bisschen hinwollen heute, ist nochmal zu zeigen, warum dieses Gewaltmonopol des Staates halt einen öffentlichen Kontrollebedarf, also warum man da genau hingucken muss, warum man sich auch tatsächlich die Details angucken muss, also wie der Staat Gewalt anwendet, warum, mit welcher Begründung und wie damit umgegangen wird, wenn es dann tatsächlich mal schiefgeht und den Leuten von Wasser nachher in die Augen aus geschossen werden. Und warum es nicht geht, dann zu sagen, ja immer bedauerliche Einzelfälle und da müssen wir mal drüber hinweg sehen.
Es sind immer alles bedauerliche Einzelfälle.
Immer bedauerliche Einzelfälle. Aber es ist halt eine systematische Angelegenheit, dass aus politischen Gründen diese Übertretung des Angemessenheitgrundsatzes für Gewaltausübung immer wieder stattfindet. Und bei Stuttgart 21 ist ganz klar der Fall, wenn wir auch noch ein bisschen begründen, woran man das erkennen kann, dass es politisch gewollt war, das zu übertreten. Diese öffentliche Kontrolle bezieht sich zum Beispiel auch darauf, welche Polizeitaktik wird dann bei solchen Großlagen eingesetzt. Also wie funktioniert denn eigentlich die Taktik bei Großlagen, wenn zum Beispiel Demonstrationen sind oder wenn halt Wackerstorf anstand oder Gorleben ansteht und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Das hat durchaus einen wichtiger Aspekt der ganzen Sache, weil daraus resultiert dann auch der Fokus, wo Gewalt angewendet wird, warum Gewalt angewendet wird und welche Mittel zugelassen sind. In der Regel werden solche Großlagen, sind ja sogenannte Ereignisse, die zum Beispiel dafür da sind, Vorhaben durchzudrücken. Also wie zum Beispiel Kernkraftwerke zu bauen, Atomentlager zu bauen. Was haben wir noch jetzt gerade? Immobilien zu bauen und irgendwie Bahnhof zu nennen. Also muss man sich mal vergegenwärtigen. Diese ganze Stuttgart 21 Geschichte dient ja nur als Begründung dafür, da einen riesigen, fetten Immobilien Deal da ringsrum durchzuziehen und noch ein ganzes Viertel aus dem Boden zu stampfen.
Dazu wir übrigens auch sagen sollten, da gab es heute die schöne Geschichte, also das ist eigentlich schon eine ganz alte Geschichte, aber es gab die Geschichte, dass die Mafia in Stuttgart eine Hochburg hatte und dass deren traditionelles Gebiet die Immobilienabzocke ist. Also die beteiligen sich an Immobilien Deals und machen dann da Schutzgeld obendrauf und machen dann hier noch eine Gebühr und da noch eine Gebühr und stellen es halt zu hoch in Rechnung. Und so machen die da ihren Profit und das ist seit vielen Jahren so. Und es gibt Verbindung zur CDU natürlich, die Details werden wir verlinken. Aber so ist das also, wenn wir sagen mafiöse Strukturen?
Das ist durchaus wörtlich zunehmend.
Das muss man, das ist nicht im übertragenen Sinn gemeint.
Ja, wie gesagt, solche Sachen durchzudrücken, dazu bedarf es dann, wenn die Bevölkerung ungern möchte, dass es passiert, dann eben des staatlichen Gewaltmonopols bzw. des Missbrauchs dasselben. Eine sehr übliche Anwendungsmöglichkeit dafür ist, auch politische Demonstrationen zu diskreditieren. Also es hängt ja auch immer sehr davon ab, wie sich die Polizei bei solchen Demonstrationen verhält, ob die dann plötzlich gewalttätig werden oder nicht. Es wird halt durchaus gerne verwendet. Es gibt auch legitime Sachen, wie z.B. verfeindete Blöcke zu trennen bei Fußballspielen oder bei Antifa versus Nazi-Geschichten, wo es dann halt immer hochgradig problematisch ist, weil die spezifische Art der Anwendung der Gewalt oder des Einsatzes der Polizeitaktik sorgt natürlich immer wieder für Probleme, wenn wir halt irgendwie sehen, die Nazis dürfen dann marschieren und die gegen Demonstranten werden weggehalten. Und dergleichen Dinge mehr gibt es ja immer wieder.
Das ist auch ein regionales Problem. In manchen Bezirken schützen sie halt die Linken und in anderen beschützen sie ja die Nazis vor den Linken.
Kann man so nicht pauschal sagen. Das ist halt schon eher...
Also diese Nazi-Demos, die beschützt wurden, die gab es eigentlich hauptsächlich in Sachsen oder nicht?
Die gab es auch an Berlin.
An Berlin auch?
Oder? War echt nicht so selten. Es war dann schon häufiger so, dass sie dann nicht so richtig Bock hatten und die dann vorzeitig beendet haben, weil sie gesagt haben, sie können sich nicht mehr beschützen gehabt. Natürlich auch. Aber es ist nicht so, dass... Wir haben es versucht. Ich kann dir mal ein bisschen erzählen, wie ich beobachte die Sache mit dem Polizeiennsatz eigentlich seit den frühen 90er Jahren. Und zwar beruht darauf, dass ich früher mal so irgendwie vier, fünf Querstraßen weg von der Mainzer Straße gewohnt habe. Das war sozusagen meine Nachbarschaft. Und für die, die es nicht mehr wissen, die Mainzer Straße war die zweite nahezu vollständig besetzte Straße in Deutschland. Das heißt also, wo halt eine ganze Häuserzeile besetzt war. Heute Nacht, da Wende, standen die Häuser leer, da war halt niemand und da sind die Leute halt eingezogen und haben halt alle coole Sachen gemacht. Also da gab es zum Beispiel ein Schwulen- und Hundenhaus und Häuser, die alle möglichen interessanten Lebensalternativen umgesetzt haben. Es gab halt auch durchaus eine Menge Sofie-Punkster und eine Menge Leute, die da halt einfach nur abgehangen haben. Aber auch viele Künstler und Leute, wo man sagt, ja cool, schön, dass die da mal so ihren Freiraum haben. Und dann nach dem Vollzug der Wiedervereinigung ging der Senat daran, die Berliner Linie durchzusetzen. Das heißt, alle Häuser zu räumen oder mit einem Vertrag zu versehen, die zu räumen, die sich nicht unter Vertragsbindung nehmen lassen wollten. Und dann eskalierte das in einer Situation vor sich hin, die dann dazu führte, dass an beiden Enden, beziehungsweise an allen drei Enden der Mainzer Straße so eine t-förmige Angelegenheit, Barrikaden standen und die Polizei sagte so, wir wollen jetzt hier mal räumen und die Leute da drinnen sagten, nö.
Wem haben denn die Häuser gehört, Gamst?
Die Häuser gehörten zu verschiedenen, war teilweise, war es unklar, teilweise gehörten es privaten Leuten, teilweise gehörte es noch irgendwie der KWV, also der kommunalen Wohnungsverwaltung und es war dann halt so, dass sie ausgehen von einem Räumungsversuch an einem einzelnen Haus von einem privaten Investor, ist die Situation dann halt so vor sich hin eskaliert, dass sie da dann halt alles geräumt haben. Das war so meine erste Begegnung mit Polizei im Westen, so Polizei im Osten war mir so massiv und gewalttätig noch nicht begegnet. Das war schon sehr beeindruckend. Seitdem hab ich mich so ein bisschen dafür interessiert, wie funktioniert denn das eigentlich? Also wie sieht denn die Taktik aus? Wie gehen die denn vor? Und da gab's natürlich in Berlin, gibt's halt natürlich immer den 30. April und den 1. Mai, also die Weipogesnacht und den 1. Mai, wo hier traditionell zum einen die Weipogesnacht stattfindet, zum anderen halt die 1. Mai-Demonstrationen, die durchaus häufiger mal zu minderfriedlichen Enden führen. Und da kann man halt sehr schön sehen, wie sich denn so die Polizeitaktik entwickelt hat so in den letzten, na, mittlerweile mehr als 15 Jahren. Am Anfang war es halt tatsächlich so, dass die Berliner Polizei genau das getan hat, was sie jetzt auch in Stuttgart versucht haben, nämlich halt so eine Linie zu bilden, die Linie zu halten und Leute abzudrängen und irgendwie durch linieraren Einsatz von Knüppelgewalt, Wasserwerfer und Regengas zu zerstreuen.
Wobei so gut lief das ja nicht in Stuttgart.
Nee, es lief ja eben nicht gut.
Nein, aber ich meine, das war nicht so, dass die da irgendwie eine stringente Linie hatten. Sondern die haben mal hier geprügelt und mal da geprügelt.
Das funktioniert ja auch nicht. Was ich gerade erklären will, ist die Evolution von Taktik. Also zu damaligen Zeit, also zu Anfang der 90er-Jahre, war so, dass die polizeiliche Ausrüstung ja auch noch im Wesentlichen so aus solchen Sachen wie, die hatten noch ein Schild mit und hatten zum Beispiel keine Körperpanzerung. Das heißt also, wenn die im Steinhagel standen, dann mussten die halt wirklich so wie...
Römer Schild.
Ja, Römer Schild. Also tatsächlich hat die Taktik von damals auch noch sehr viel mehr mit so griechischer und römischer Hopliten-Taktik zu tun und Legionärstaktik zu tun. Nur, dass sie halt keine Speere haben, sondern halt nur Knüppel. Und dementsprechend organisierte sich dann halt auch das Vorgehen. Also es gab dann halt so richtig Ausfälle. Also das hieß dann tatsächlich auch so. Gibt's auch immer noch, ne? Dass die dann halt da so raus stürmen und dann versuchen irgendwie, die sozusagen so einen Keil rein zu treiben und so. Aber das funktioniert halt nicht, weil in dem Umblick ist der...
Hat was von Asteroids und Obelix, ne?
Ja, hat tatsächlich was. Und über die letzten Jahre sind aber so, dass in Berlin Leute die Polizeitaktik bei solchen Großlagen bestimmen, die sich sehr genau angeguckt haben, was denn schief geht und wie es funktioniert und die dann intelligentere Konzepte entwickeln. Und eines dieser Konzepte, also der wesentliche Konzept ist dieses Balina-Phasen-Modell. Es funktioniert halt so, dass wenn erstmal die Demo ist, dann gucken sie intensiv, wer ist denn da? Und dann gibt es so eine Klassifizierung in Farbenkategorien. Also die, und zwar von Leuten, die sie so von Angesicht kennen oder anhand des Kleidungsstils oder ihres Benehmens einklassifizieren in so grün, gelb und rot und normales Bürgertum, also normale Mitläufer. Dann gibt es noch so diese berühmte Kategorie des erlebnisorientierten Jugendlichen, der sozusagen, wenn irgendwie irgendwas losgeht, Willens ist da halt...
Krawalltourist, von der Polizei benannt, ne?
Mitzumachen, die ja, Krawalltouristen, also in dieser internen Kategorie, so kommt das Wort nicht vor, sondern das ist halt schon stringent da.
Erlebnisorientiert, das ist ein internes Polizeivor?
Und der, äh, also das ist so die erste Phase. Das heißt, die gucken halt, wer ist denn da, wie viele Leute sind da, welche Gruppen kommen dazu, wie viel An- und Abstrom gibt es und gucken sich das halt alle in Ruhe an. Dann sind halt meistens auch Zivilpolizisten unter Demonstranten, die sich halt an die Gruppen ranmischen, von denen sie davon ausgehen, dass da von denen möglicherweise Gewalt ausgehen könnte. Häufig genug ist es offensichtlich auch so, dass die Zivilpolizisten provozieren, also dass von denen denn schon mal gerne der erste Steiner die erste Flasche geworfen wird. Wenn nicht genug los ist, wird das natürlich immer wieder abgestretten und die Polizei dementiert hat natürlich, dass sowas passiert. Aber es gibt da genügend Hinweise darauf, dass es passiert. Also auch jetzt zum Beispiel diese Geschichte in Stuttgart, die sie jetzt gerade gebracht haben, da hatten sie ja so ein Video, wo man so einen Typen sieht, der sich von hinten durch die Demonstranten durchdringelt, auf die Polizei zu und mit Pfefferspray so auf die Polizei sprüht. Das war dieser berühmte Demonstrant namens Pfefferspray zuerst eingesetzt.
Natürlich.
Wenn man sich dieses Video mal durchguckt, dann sieht man, dass der Pfefferspray eine verblüffende Ähnlichkeit mit denen aufweist, die die Polizisten hatten. Also das schien dann bestimmt jemand fallen lassen, und er hat ihn hochgenommen. Keine Ahnung so. Und zum anderen sprüht er halt nicht auf Gesichtshöhe, wie man das tun würde, wenn man weiß, was man tut, sondern er sprüht auf Brusthöhe, und zwar offensichtlich absichtlich. Das heißt, die Polizisten hat es nicht interessiert, die haben dann halt hier müssen abwischen und sind immer gut. So, das heißt, also das war meine Vermutung, ich kann das nicht belegen, aber ich halte das für einen Agent Provokateur.
Da vielleicht die Anekdote am Rande erzählen aus dem Juretzko Buch. Da gab es mal die Anekdote, dass sie die BND-Agenten an ihrem Schuhwerk erkannt haben, weil keiner aus der BND Kleiderkammer kam, die sahen alle gleich aus. Das nächste Mal bei Provokatoren vielleicht auch auf die Schuhe gucken. Da gab es jetzt auch aus dem kanadischen...
Aus vancouver.
Aus vancouver gab es auch so ein paar Bilder von fiesen Demonstranten, die sich da mit der Polizei duelliert haben. Und die haben auch exakt dasselbe Schuhwerk angehabt, wie die Polizisten so schwarze, ich würde nicht sagen Springerstiefel, aber so in die Richtung.
Passte schon, ja.
Tja, so wiederholt sich das.
Das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man halt einfach mit rechnen muss. Also es ist nicht so, dass wenn da Leute durchdrehen, also das so aussieht, als wenn sie durchdrehen, dann plötzlich anfangen Steine vor dem Körper an, Glasflaschen zu schmeißen. Das sind unbedingt Leute, die jetzt von sich aus Radale machen wollen, sondern es ist durchaus auch so, dass bei den Civis offensichtlich etliche dabei sind, die sowas dann gerne mal tun. So wie gesagt, die Polizei streitet immer ab und die kann es auch nicht beweisen, aber zumindest aus meiner Beobachtung von solchen Situationen sind das Leute, die man vorher und nachher da drin nie wieder gesehen hat und die auch nie festgenommen wurden. Was hochgradig erstaunlich ist, weil zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist es meistens so, dass zum einen halt schon eine Menge Civis da gibt, zum anderen intensiv gefilmt wird. Das heißt also alle möglichen Handlungen werden halt gefilmt. Und es gibt da eine so eine Berliner Besonderheit, die in Berlin zuerst eingeführt wurde, nämlich die Beweissicherungs- und Festnahmeeinheiten. Das sind die Leute, die haben keine Schilde mehr, sondern die sind halt mit Körperpanzung unterwegs.
Und die greifen gezielt einzelne Leute raus.
Genau, die sind halt dafür da, Beweissicherung, also festzustellen, ob jemand Steine schmeißt oder dergleichen Dinge mehr, und die dann rauszugreifen, also auch an denen dran zu bleiben und die zu beobachten, bis die Gelegenheit günstig ist. Und das ist halt so die Phase 1. Und wenn sie halt merken, dass jetzt die Sache langsam so ein bisschen anfängt brenzlicher zu werden, dann gibt es die Phase 2, sondern das Durchmischen. Was dann passiert ist dann, also meistens ist es dann statische Situation, zum Beispiel am Endplatz der Demo oder bei Blockaden davor. Und dann fangen die halt an, mit so 10er-Zügen durch die Demonstranten durchzulaufen, und zwar richtig so durchzurempeln. So, also richtig so, immer kreuz und quer, wo immer Leute dicht beieinander stehen, laufen sie dann so durch und rempeln dann mal so ein bisschen und gucken, wer versucht, sie anzugreifen. Wer sie angreift, wird sofort von 10 Mann runtergerissen und mitgenommen. Das heißt, wenn man sieht, dass diese Phase beginnt und die Leute dann, also die da anfangen, so durch die Gegend zu laufen, denen einfach immer hübsch aus dem Weg gehen, den Platz machen so und sich mit seinen Freunden woanders hinstellen, was die halt versuchen, es ungemütlich zu machen. Das heißt, es sind dann zum Beispiel auch solche Phasen, wenn bei der Viporisnacht ist, ist es dann die Phase, wo sie anfangen, die Scheinwerfer anzumachen. Das heißt, so etakel auszuleuchten, grill, sodass es wirklich ungemütlich wird und die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben, da zu bleiben.
Das ist doch durchaus Erfolg.
Ja, das funktioniert sehr gut. Das Ziel davon ist, keine Konzentrationen zuzulassen. Also zu verhindern, dass sich Leute zusammenrotten und zu sagen, komm, jetzt hauen wir die da hinten mal aufs Maul. Das ist das Ziel davon und das funktioniert sehr erfolgreich. Das ist die kritische Innovation dabei. Und wenn sich das allgemein zerstreut hat und die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben und lieber saufen gehen und dann nur noch wenige da sind, dann gehen sie halt davon aus, dass zu diesem Zeitpunkt sind aber auf jeden Fall noch die Leute da, die hardcore-leute, die dafür angereist sind. Und dann setzen sie die Beweislichungs- und Festnahmeeinheiten ein, um diese Leute gezielt zu greifen. Und das kann dann auch extrem hässlich sein. Also es ist halt so, dass diese Beweislichungs- und Festnahmeeinheiten, dass die nicht zimperlich sind, wäre eine echte Untertreibung. Also da werden halt systematisch irgendwie Arme verdreht und irgendwie Gelenke überdehnt und so. Also es ist halt nicht schön. Und in der Wanne wird dann auch gerne nochmal draufgehauen. Und so. Das ist halt so ein...
Also die Wanne ist ein Berliner Polizeifahrzeug.
Die Wanne ist ein Berliner Polizeifahrzeug.
Das ist halt alter Mercedes-Bus normalerweise.
Ja. Und dann so die Phase 4 ist dann halt, wenn dann alle keinen Bock mehr haben, nach Hause gehen, halt zu managen, dass sich keine neuen Konzentrationen bilden, dass halt keine neuen Demonstrationen entstehen. Eben auch durch einfach Hinschicken von Polizisten durchrennen lassen, ungemütlich machen und so. Und das ist also die Taktik, die dazu geführt hat, dass seit den letzten Jahren halt eigentlich zum 1. Mai praktisch nichts mehr an ländswerten Gewaltausbrüchen war. Auch wenn es in der Springerpresse immer anders aussah, ist überhaupt gar kein Vergleich zu dem, was noch vor zehn Jahren da so war. Und das ist tatsächlich eine Taktik, also Taktikinnovation, wo man halt etwas sagen muss, die haben sich angeguckt, was ist das Problem?
Wir haben jemanden gefragt, der sich mit so was auskennt.
Oder sich Leute dazu ausgebildet, die haben ja auch tatsächlich da Führungsakademien und das Problem damit gelöst. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal angucken, was haben die in Stuttgart falsch gemacht? Was die in Stuttgart hätten machen müssen, wenn sie irgendwie Ahnung von Taktik gehabt hätten, wäre halt einfach die Linie halten, dann nichts weiter tun. Also einfach nur nicht zurückweichen und dann halt einfach ihre, weiß ich, Hundertfestnahme halten, da kreuz und quer durchschicken, bis die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben und nach Hause gehen.
Nein, nicht mal das hätten sie tun müssen. Also auf diesem taktischen Video, das wir auch noch mal hier verlinken werden, konnte man sehr gut sehen, dass die da sich in Scharmützel begeben haben, an Gebieten, die überhaupt nicht notwendig waren für ihre Aufgabe. Also die Aufgabe war, dass diese Baufahrzeuge auf einer kaum wirklich winzigen Nadel über durch müssen. Und wenn sie das geräumt hätten, dann hätten sie einfach die Leute daneben, die saßen auf Bäumen, die gar nicht abgeholzt hätten werden sollen an dem Tag. Dass sie sich denen überhaupt gewidmet haben, ist totaler Schwachsinn. Also das war echt immer völlig sinnlos. Wahrscheinlich, weil die gefilmt haben, ne?
Nee, es war nicht sinnlos. Worum es da ging, war eine politische Machtdemonstration. Das ist halt eben der auch einen...
Oh, das ist natürlich die Theorie gerade, dass die ZNU-Taktik ist an der Stelle...
Also wenn du dir die Polizeitaktik anguckst und die Wahl der Einsatzmittel und die Geschwindigkeit der Eskalation, die da gewählt wurde, dann hatten die ganz klar die Anweisung von oben, haut da mal so drauf, dass da keiner mehr Bock hat zu demonstrieren. Und das war die Anweisung. Und dann kam ihnen halt diese Schülerdemo, da durfte dazwischen, weil irgendwie haben sie offensichtlich...
Das waren Kommunikationsverkacker.
Eigentlich hatten die zwei Stunden später anfangen sollen. Die hätten zwei Stunden später anfangen sollen mit den Baumaßnahmen. Ja, das wussten die. Also die haben sehr versucht. Also der interessante Punkt war, dass sie offensichtlich versucht haben, diese Baumaßnahmen vorzuziehen, vor den eigentlich verkündeten Terminen, weil sie wussten, dass ihr eigenes Innenministerium leaky ist und die Leute, die Demonstranten, wussten, wann die eigentlich Baumaßnahmen anfangen sollten. Und bei diesem Vorziehen dieser Maßnahme haben sie offensichtlich verpeilt, dass da die Schülerdemo war. Und dann, als es ihnen gesagt wurde, dass das so war, haben sie sich darüber hinweggesetzt und gesagt, der macht mal trotzdem, haut ihn mal aufs Mauer. Also das ist zumindest das, was ich daraus deute, wie dieser ganze Einsatz gelaufen ist. Also das ist halt so ein Ding, was man mittlerweile etwas seltener sieht, aber immer wieder, dass es nämlich eine politische Anweisung gibt, eben nicht zu deeskalieren, sondern dafür zu sorgen, dass die Kosten der politischen Malungsäußerungen gesteigert werden. Und das ist tatsächlich durchaus auch eine Funktion von solchen Polizeieinsätzen bei Großleuten.
Aber auch dieser Hamburger Kessel war ja relativ bekannt dafür.
Genau, diese Hamburger Geschichte, dass man sich dann schon überlegen muss, ob man jetzt für seine politische Meinung auf die Straße geht und dafür riskiert, irgendwie aufs Mal zu bekommen.
Und nicht denkbar ungeschickt aus PR-Gründen, als die Schüler zu verprügeln, aber naja.
Genau.
Ja, wie kommt denn das, dass so eine Handvoll Polizisten, also gut, das sah jetzt nicht so wenig aus, aber dass so eine Handvoll Polizisten im Grunde eine viel größere Menge an Demonstranten in Schach halten können?
Na, da kann man mal so die World of Warcraft-Assoziationen verwenden. Die passen da tatsächlich.
Der Org-Mob.
Das sind halt tatsächlich Force-Multiplier. Also die, wenn man sich das so anguckt, die Strategie in Abwesenheit von Feuerwaffen. Also die haben zwar noch Feuerwaffen, aber die einzusetzen ist halt Ultima Ratio. Das machen sie halt wirklich nur, wenn es nicht mehr anders geht. Das gibt halt immer gleich so viel schlechte Pressen, so viel Papierkrampen, dass das unerwünscht ist. Und davon können wir sozusagen mal außen vor lassen, denn die Ultima Ratio, wenn es gar nicht anders geht. Aber was sie halt haben, ist halt Ausrüstung. Das heißt also in der Regel Körperpanzerung, in der Regel Helme, in der Regel Knüppel. Da gehen wir noch mal im Einzelnen drauf ein. Die ihnen einen Gewaltvorteil gegenüber normalen unbewaffneten Demonstranten gibt. Das ist halt schon ganz klar. Also du kannst, wenn du gepanzert bist, interessieren die Standorte nicht so. Wenn du einen Knüppel in der Hand hast, interessiert dich ein Forstschlag nicht. Das ist halt eine klare Sache. Wenn du Trägen hast und eine Gasmaske hast, so dann hast du halt massiven Force-Multiplier. Das zweite ist Training. Diese Art und Weise des Vorgehens, also zu wissen, wie verhalten sich Leute, wenn Gewalt eingesetzt wird. Und zu wissen, unter welchen Umständen reagieren Leute wie. Das machen die den ganzen Tag. Also diese geschlossenen Einheiten, zum Beispiel von der Bundespolizei oder von Landespolizeien, die machen nichts weiter den ganzen Tag, wenn sie nicht gerade am Einsatz sind, als sowas zu trainieren. Das sieht dann tatsächlich so aus, dass sie, also bei den Polizeischülern, da hatte ich mal die Gelegenheit, das zu beobachten, die trainieren tatsächlich auch unter Echtbedingungen. Also es ist halt dann so, dass die, dann wird die eine Hälfte als Demonstranten abgestellt und am Anfang kriegen sie halt Tischtennisbälle statt Steine und dann brüllen die halt auch richtig so dieselben Parolen, die auf den Demonstrationen gebrüllt werden. Die gucken sich halt vorher auch Videos an, damit sie das wissen können und werden dann auch schon zudringlich und so. Und die Abschlussprüfung ist dann zumindest bei der einen Geschichte, die ich da beobachten konnte, dann tatsächlich wirklich mit Pflastersteinen. Also dann müssen die Polizeischüler Schildigel bilden und die anderen dürfen mit Pflastersteinen schmeißen. Das ist halt psychologisch sehr interessant, weil die eine Hälfte erst auf der Schildigel muss.
Es ist eigentlich schade, dass sie da nicht Statisten nehmen, oder? Da wüsste ich ein paar Leute, die würden das sogar freiwillig machen. Oh, Pflastersteine auf Polizisten, na klar. Aber die Bundeswehr hat auch Trainingsgebiete für sowas. Aber die sind nicht für den Inneneinsatz, oder wie ist da der Deal?
Na die sind offiziell natürlich nur für Training in Afghanistan, also dass sie halt Demonstrationen in Afghanistan gewurrt bekommen, ohne dass sie da gleich zu letaler Gewalt greifen müssen. Und interessanterweise...
Ist es überhaupt deren Aufgabe, da Demonstrationen zu befrieden?
Naja...
Also ich meine, wieso muss unsere Armee das überhaupt üben, wie man mit Demonstrationen umgeht?
Naja, weil in Abwesenheit von irgendwie einer Polizei, die dafür sorgen kann, dass der Mob nicht an den Stützpunkt stürmt, dann...
Na natürlich, ich meine, du musst ja nirgendswo hin, du kannst die doch da demonstrieren lassen.
Na ich weiß nicht genau, ich glaube, dass die Überlegung dabei schon war zu sagen, wir müssen nicht gleich immer anfangen zu schießen, wenn tausend Leute vor der Tür stehen, was sie bisher offensichtlich genahren haben, zum Beispiel die Luft.
Also du meinst aber, das ist nicht irgendwie Vorbereitung auf den Inneneinsatz?
Das würde ich schon sehen, dass es so ist, dass es eine Vorbereitung auf den Inneneinsatz ist. Also die Art und Weise dieser Trainings, auch was die Amis hier trainiert haben, die amerikanische Polizei, haben ja genau auch dieselben Trainingsgebiete benutzt. Und auch die Verwendung der Bundespolizei als Ausbilder für die afghanische Polizei und Almeda, das verschwimmt immer mehr. Also die Grenzen sind fließend und ich würde jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass man da immer sagen kann, das ist das, das ist das. Im Zweifel haben wir denn schon große Kontingente Bundeswehr, die im Inneren einsetzbar sind. Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, dass die Wehrpflicht fällt, ist halt der Nachteil einer abgeschafften Wehrpflicht, dass die Leute dann da auf Jaraka saniert sind, ein Fremdes von der Bevölkerung und durchaus eben auch im Inneren einsetzbar werden.
Naja, aber im Moment, du hast ja eh keine Wehrpflichtigen, die du da hinschickst nach Afghanistan, das sind eh nur Wehrpflichtige.
Nee, aber wenn wir jetzt mal vom Bundeswehr-Einsatz im Inneren als Szenario ausgehen und sagen, wir haben jetzt da eine Bundeswehr, die im Zweifel, wenn halt die...
Stimmt natürlich, dass sie dann weniger Hemmungen haben, die die Leute zu verprügeln, weil sie die ja nicht...
Weil, das wäre eine interessante Frage, weil an der Mainzer Straße war der so, dass die zumindest dem, was dann hinterher so an Protokollen und so durchsickern nach, haben die sich schon ernsthaft überlegt, was sie denn jetzt tun, wenn sie da nicht durchkommen. Ja, weil die kamen halt drei Tage nicht durch. Die standen halt da vor den Barrikaden und haben es immer wieder versucht mit den Wasserwerfern. Die Straße war so dermaßen voll mit Regengas, so einen dichten Nebel hast du noch nicht gesehen.
Vorsprung durch Technik.
Ja, und da war eben der Unterschied, und das ist halt eben genau dieser Punkt der nächste, dass die Leute, die da drinnen waren, haben halt geschlossen gehandelt. Und das ist halt der wesentliche Unterschied auch, die du beim Training lernst als Polizist, ist halt geschlossen vorgehen. Du bleibst in deiner Einheit, du hast eine Aufgabe, du erfüllst diese Aufgabe. Du hast halt ein Ziel.
Das ist ja ungewöhnlich für Demonstrationen eigentlich, dass die Leute so...
Gibt's nicht. Also gibt's de facto nicht. Und das war, wie gesagt, einer der wenigen Fälle, wo es halt so war. Also in der Meinser, weil die Leute halt bedingt durch die Umstände ein gemeinsames Ziel hatten, nämlich die kommen da nicht durch. Also es war halt nicht so, dass sie sich dazu abgesprochen hatten oder jetzt lange dafür trainiert haben oder dergleichen Dinge mehr, sondern es war halt einfach nur so eine Festungssituation.
Also funktioniert es eben, wenn du unter Druck bist, dann funktioniert Zusammenarbeit plötzlich. Eine Sache habe ich noch mit dem Militär. Wir haben neulich mal darüber nachgedacht, wie denn das eigentlich mit den Chemiewaffen ist. Und da gibt es halt so ein Abkommen und das untersagt unter anderem der Bundeswehr den Einsatz von sowas wie CSKAS.
Nicht nur der Bundeswehr, international ein Militärs.
Ja. Und wie ist denn das damit zu vereinigen, dass die dann doch damit trainieren? Also ist das nur für den Einsatz tatsächlich? Oder trainieren darfst du schon damit?
Also der, ähm, die...
Ist ja natürlich auch eigentlich nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, dass du trainieren und das dann nicht einsetzen darfst.
Na, die Grundlage des Chemiewaffenabkommens, des Verbots von so genannten Irritationsstoffen da drin waren die so genannten Maskenbrecher im ersten Weltkrieg. Das heißt also, die haben unter den Begriffen bunte Schießen, so hieß es damals, mehrere Stoffe durcheinander geschossen und einige davon waren welche, die unwillbares Erbrechen auslösten.
Ach, und dann musstest du die Grasmaske abnehmen?
Und dann konnte halt das eigentliche Kampfgas, was dein Lungen geschädigt hat oder deine Augen geschädigt hat, halt rücken. Und daher konnte halt das Verbot von diesen Stoffen als Kriegswaffe. Und es ist halt so, dass es halt relativ harmlos im Vergleich zu richtigem Kampfgas angesehen wird, weswegen Grasmasken einsetzt, dass zum Beispiel eine Bundeswehr damit trainiert wird. Also die schicken dich dann halt, also du legst deine ABC-Ausrüstung an und dann schmeißt du eine Gasgranate in das geschlossene Zelt und dann wird geguckt, ob du deine Gasmaske richtig aufgesetzt hast. Und wenn du rausrennen musst, weil dir gerade schlecht wird und dann aufdrehen, hast du wohl deine Gasmaske nicht richtig aufgesetzt. Das ist halt so einer dieser Dinge, die halt militär ist halt zu tun. In dem Chemiewürfeln Übereinkommen steht aber, dass, und das ist ein Zitat, Substanzen zur Bekämpfung von Unruhen davon ausgenommen sind, solange sie nicht vorm Militär eingesetzt wurden. Also wenn es einen Bundeswehr-Einsatz im Inneren gäbe, dürfte die Bundeswehr keinen CS einsetzen, wohl aber die Polizei.
Genau, na die dürfen ja auch generell, also die...
Na für die Polizei ist es halt so, da gibt es halt zugelassene Einsatzmittel. Und die werden, da gibt es halt in jedem Bundesland so ein Zertifizierungsverfahren, zugelassene Stoffe und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und da, also wo zum Beispiel so ein Pfeffersprayer darauf geprüft wird, wie weit er sprüht, bei welchen Temperaturen, wie groß das Trefferbild ist, da kommen wir gleich noch dazu. Und diese Einsatzmittel werden dann halt eben entsprechend freigegeben, entsprechend der Polizeitaktik. Das heißt also in Berlin ist es zum Beispiel so, dass der Einsatz von Wasserwerfern oder von Tränengas muss immer von der obersten Heeresleitung genehmigt werden. Also so, dass die die Polizei... Also von dem Einsatzleiter. Von der Einsatzleitung in dem Fall. Und das ist halt auch so ein interessantes Kennzeichen der Berliner Polizeitaktik, dass die doch ein erstaunliches Maß an Neukomanagement machen. Also die oberste Polizeiführung schreibt den Hundertschaften schon sehr genau vor, was sie da tun und lassen sollen. Unter anderem auch, ob sie mit Blaulicht fahren dürfen oder nicht. Wenn gerade noch die Eskalation angesetzt ist, dann dürfen sie nur ohne Blaulicht fahren. Wenn gerade Eskalationsphase ist, dann wird ihnen gesagt, machen sie mal Blaulicht an.
Machen sie Basireen.
Also es hat schon eine relativ umfangreiche Kontrolle, die da ausgeübt wird.
Gibt es da auch Einschränkungen vom Dabeihaben? Also darf zum Beispiel jemand, der Fahrradfahrer beim Rotlicht überqueren kontrolliert, darf der auch Reizgas dabei haben? Oder sind das nur bestimmte Einheiten?
Also ein Pfefferspray oder ein CS-Sprüher gehört in der Regel zur persönlichen Ausrüstung. Also das wird auch regelmäßig eingesetzt bei Festnahmen und so. Das ist also normale persönliche Straßenausrüstung.
Ach, also das heißt, wenn du jemanden genug anpinkelst, der dich mit dem Auto in einer Mausepfalle kontrolliert, weil du zu schnell gefahren bist, dann können die auch mal Reizgas...
Na klar, ist zugelassen. Zählt als einfache körperliche Gewalt. So, also die können halt einen Knüppel rausholen, aber machen sie meistens ungern, weil mittlerweile gibt es eine Menge Leute da draußen, die können besser mit dem Knüppel umgehen als sie. Und dann wird halt meistens dann Reizgas eingesetzt. Das ist also durchaus üblich. Also es gibt halt jedes Jahr hunderte Einsätze von CS beziehungsweise Fever-Spray, auch so im normalen Alltagsbetrieb.
Was ist denn, wenn die jetzt auf jemanden treffen, der Reizgas gegen sie einsetzt? Weil sagen wir mal, ich meine, viele Frauen haben das ja dabei. Aus Angst vor Vergewaltigungen. Ist das dann auch irgendwie verboten?
Natürlich, tätlicher Angriff auf einen Polizeibeamten. Versuchte Körperverletzung.
Okay, also es ist genauso, als wenn du denen irgendwie hauen würdest.
Zählt genauso, ja. Dieses geschlossene Handeln, was ich gerade sagte, ist halt auch so ein Punkt, den lernen die halt auch in den Trainings. Und halt Kommunikation, heißt hier im Funkgeräte. Die haben eine Hierarchie, also halt ein strukturiertes Vorgehen, quasi militärisch in dem Sinne. Demgegenüber sind sie halt dann natürlich so Demonstranten, die maximal eine Koordination innerhalb ihres Freundeskreises haben. Oder wenn man jetzt mal von organisierten Aktivistengruppen ausgeht, die mal so ein Blockadetraining machen, also wie man sich zum Beispiel hinsetzt bei so einer Sitzblockade, sich unterhakt und wenn man halt loslässt und sich wegträgt.
Ist das öffentlich oder?
Ja, viele Aktivistengruppen, gerade im Anti-Atom-Umfeld, machen Aktivistentrainings, wo sie den Leuten beibringen, wie man zum Beispiel eine Sitzblockade qualifiziert macht, was man sich anzieht, was die Rechte sind, wie man verhindert, dass die einen aufs Maul hauen, wenn die sich an ihre Gesetze halten. Also wenn die sich in ihre Polizeidienstvorschrift halten.
Naja, dann muss ja immer die Hoffnung muss auch.
Manchmal ist es tatsächlich so, dass sie sich dran halten, oft genug halt nicht. Also der große Teil dieser polizeilichen Handlungen wird die sogenannte Polizeidienstvorschrift geregelt. In diesem Fall ist es die PDV 100 und die ist geheim.
Sagen wir mal, wollen wir nicht mehr so einen, so jemanden zum Kongress einladen?
Der uns was über die PDV 100 erzählt?
Nee, der uns zeigt, wie man Sitzblockaden qualifiziert macht.
Ja, das können wir machen. Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen kalt draußen.
Na, dann können wir doch drinnen üben, oder?
Ja, können wir machen.
Ist doch eh eng genug da.
Es gibt bestimmt Ärger mit der Feuerwehr. Nee, also gibt es von allen möglichen Organisationen, die gerade im Anti-Atom-Umfeld unterwegs sind, die machen solche Trainings. Unter anderem auch deswegen, um Leuten zu vermitteln, dass man selbst vor solcher Gewaltandrohung nicht zurückschrecken muss. Also, dass das halt in gewisser Art und Weise beherrschbar ist. Das kann natürlich immer sein, wie beim G8 zum Beispiel, wo sie die Leute dann halt zwar irgendwie halbwegs zivil weggetragen haben, an einigen Stellen, an anderen Stellen aber halt super ultra brutal zugeschlagen haben.
Und dann bist du in den Käfig.
Und sich dann rechtswidrig in den Käfig gesperrt haben und du 48 Stunden nicht mehr einen Anwalt gesehen hast. Das kann dir natürlich halt auch passieren. Und da kann dir Training halt im Wesentlichen wenig helfen. Der Vorteil ist aber, dass du halt in Zweifel Leute kennst. Also, dass du halt bei diesen Trainingsleute kennenlernst und in Zweifel mit diesen Leuten zusammen dann zu der Sitzblockade gehst und man sich gegenseitig halt hilft und unterstützt. Das ist halt schon ein großer Vorteil.
Als Zeuge zur Verfügung steht.
Als Zeuge zur Verfügung steht, ja. Noch so eine Sache, die die Polizei halt lernt bei solchen Sachen, ist halt keine Angst vor Gewaltausübung zu haben. Das heißt also, denen wird da systematisch abtrainiert. Gewalt, also dieses, wo Leute zurückschrecken, normalerweise Gewalt auszuüben, ist eine Sache, die so im angeborenen Reflex, man übt nicht gerne Gewalt gegen Menschen aus, das wird ihnen da abtrainiert. Also das heißt, diese Hemmschwörre zu überwinden, ist Bestandteil des Trainings. Ja, spannend bei diesen ganzen Sachen ist natürlich die, warum geht es denn immer wieder schief? Also nicht nur absichtlich, wenn halt die Politik sagt, wir wollen jetzt mal drauf gehauen haben, sondern auch unabsichtlich. Weil jedes Jahr gibt es Fälle, wo so ein Hundertschaftsführer völlig im Wald steht, nicht weiß, wo oben und unten es Anweisungen gibt, die halt völlig illusorisch sind. Und es gibt halt zwar nicht diese Polizeidienstvorschrift, die ist wie gesagt nicht erhältlich für den normalen staplichen. Aber es gibt die Kommentare dazu, also das Lehrmaterial, die kann man sich tatsächlich auch noch einmal sehen.
Ach, und das ist frei?
Ja, das ist frei. Das ist tatsächlich etwas teuer, kostet irgendwie 70 Euro oder so. Ich glaube, im Beutfall hast du das erschienen. Können wir mal den DOL in die Links tun. Ist zum größten Teil echt dröge, weil wird halt eine Menge erklärt, wie halt welche Vorschrift zu interpretieren ist in der PDF.
Ja, das ist doch perfekt. Dann kannst du ja die Vorschriften reverse-ingenieren daraus, oder?
Ja, zum größten Teil. Der interessante Punkt dabei ist, dann zu sehen in diesen Ausbildungsmaterialien, welche typischen Irrtümer passieren in solchen Führern, also welchen Führungspersonal bei solchen Großansätzen. Einer der wesentlichen Irrtümer ist, dass dem Gegner organisiertes Handeln unterstellt wird. Offensichtlich ist es sehr üblich, dass so ein Hundertschaftsführer erst mal annimmt, dass diese Demonstranten da alle fies organisierte Kommunisten sind, die irgendwie zehn Jahre in nordkoreanischen Metja-Ausbildungslagern waren, um irgendwie seine arme Hundertschaft zu überrennen. Das scheint so ein völlig übliches Problem zu sein.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn du übst mit der anderen Hälfte deiner Kompanie, dann ist es ja auch so.
Vermutlich, weil die, ja klar, das stimmt. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was sie da als typischen Outroom-Listen. Eine andere Sache natürlich, so der Nebel des Krieges, also wenn da an allen Ecken und Enden was passiert ist, ist es extrem schwer, den Überblick zu behalten. Häufig genug sind irgendwelche Meldungen auch falsch, die kommen. Der Klassiker sind dann immer die Fragen, halt wie viele Demonstranten sind denn da, wie viel von denen sind denn jetzt irgendwie potenziell gewaltbereit.
Persönliche Befindlichkeit des Polizisten vor Ort.
Ja, die sind dann schon ein bisschen ausgebildet und möglicherweise auch nicht so ganz von der Hand zu weisen, wenn die sagen, da sind jetzt 50, die irgendwie Trouble suchen, dann sind wahrscheinlich 20 wirklich da oder so. Aber genau diese Meldeketten, die haben dann häufiger halt auch so eine Stelle Postprinzip.
Gibt's dann da das Honecker-Prinzip?
Ja klar.
Am Ende kommen fünf Millionen Gewaltbewerber, Hooligans an.
Hooligans, die mit Panker-Hooligans, die irgendwie Kreuzberg stürmen wollen. Und noch so ein Problem sind halt die Hierarchien und vor allen Dingen auch die Kulturen in diesen geschlossenen Einheiten. Also diese geschlossenen Unwortschaften sind kaserniert. Das heißt also, die sind wie militär in einer Kaserne, wo die halt auch die ganze Zeit sind und ausgebildet werden und vorgehalten werden.
Ach, die wohnen auch gar nicht irgendwie zu Hause, sondern geschlossene Einheiten halt. Das erklärt, warum die sich auch mal gegenseitig verprügeln auf solchen Demos. Das gibt es ja gelegentlich, die lustige Stories, dass die sich gegenseitig ihre Zivis verkloppen.
Ja, ja, das passiert schon mal, das ist halt so. Und die Kulturen in diesen geschlossenen Einheiten sind teilweise auch sehr, ja, nicht besonders gewaltfern. So, also schon so, dass da, also in Berlin haben sie tatsächlich mal welche aufgelöst, weil es überhaupt nicht mehr ging. So, dann haben sie die einzelnen geschlossenen Einheiten aufgelöst, die Leute verteilt, weil sich da halt so Strukturen rausgebildet haben, die halt mit dem Rechtsstaat nicht mehr so ganz vereinbar waren und dem entsprechenden Korpsgast, der halt auch erklärt, warum so wenig Polizisten für ungerechtfertigt die Gewalt verurteilt werden. Ist halt so, dass in der Regel...
Na, und wenn halt so eine Geldstrafe, also das...
Ja, wenn überhaupt, aber das ist eine absolute extreme Ausnahmefalle. Das liegt halt daran, dass da mindestens immer drei sind, die für den Kollegen aussagen. Das ist halt völlig üblich, völlig normal und wird auch so kulturell sicherlich befördert. Und die haben...
Also da spricht ja auch nichts dagegen, wenn die nicht lügen an der Stelle. Im Grunde will man das ja nicht. Man will ja eigentlich, dass es da neutrale Zeugen gibt und es gibt ja auch die Idee, dass man eben dann so Kamerateams dahinschickt. Aber da kann man halt beobachten.
Die drehen halt die Kameras immer weg, wenn irgendwas los ist.
Sobald irgendwas aussieht, als würden jetzt die Polizisten losprügeln, dann ist die Kamera ganz schnell woanders hin.
Ja, dann gucken die, ob nicht noch irgendwo die Blümchen blühen oder die Demonstranten oder dergleichen Dinge. Und dieser Geist, der sich in diesen geschlossenen Einheiten herausbildt, ist teilweise echt extrem. Also so ein Beispiel war vor zwei Jahren oder so, war vor dreien, fuhr ich dann vom 1. Mai mal so ein bisschen rum und guckte mir die halt so an. Und die eine Hundertschaft hatten halt alle so ein schwarzes T-Shirt mit irgendwie so einem Berliner Bär mit einem Polizeiknüppel und einem Polizeihelm in der Hand. Und dem Ding so 1. Mai, ich war dabei. Oh, geil! Also so Sachen gibts da halt.
Da können wir bestimmt noch richtig irgendwie Geschäftsmittel draus machen.
Da gibts halt so eine Kultur halt. Das ist halt was man schon so sagen kann. Ja, ähm.
Tja, wo wir bei Zeugen waren, das ist auch so ein Problem häufig, dass man als Opfer von Polizeigewalt immer davon ausgeht. Guck mal, da stehen grad hundert Leute, die haben das alle gesehen. So, ich muss mir jetzt keine Sorgen machen, dass ich keine Zeugen hab vor Gericht. Und das ist halt nicht so. In der Realität sind die ganz schnell weg und denken sich, naja, irgendjemand wird schon als Zeuge aussagen. Das ist gar nicht Bösartigkeit, aber man kann das halt beobachten. Wenn man sich dann hinstellt und fragt, wer steht mir dann als Zeuge zur Verfügung, dann verflüchtet sich so eine größere Menge schon mal relativ schnell.
Ist auch häufiger so, wenn Leute dann als Zeugen versuchen in solchen Fällen auszusagen, dass sie dann nochmal eine eigene Anzeige reinkriegen. Ja, natürlich.
Aber da haben wir, glaub ich, auch noch was zu, oder? Was die Polizei im Zweifel macht, wenn man sich wehrt.
Ja, und ziehen wir später noch ein bisschen was dazu.
Es gibt da noch das Problem dadurch, dass die Polizei eben so im, ich würde nicht sagen in der Rotte, aber so im Cluster-Auftritt, dass es aus deren Perspektive so aussieht, als wenn die umzingelt sind. Also das ist zwar aus unserer Perspektive ist das auch so, aber realistisch gesehen sind wir häufig, also die Demonstranten, häufig halt viel mehr als die Polizisten. Und aus deren Sicht ist das schon psychologisch zumindest nachvollziehbar, wenn die sich umzingelt oder bedroht fühlen und dann auch mal härter zu lang als es nötig gewesen wäre. Also das ist nicht unbedingt, dass die bösartig oder zu irgendwie Wehrwülfen da... Das gibt es sicher auch, aber also das ist nicht das Hauptproblem, sondern es ist durchaus, es gibt da auch verstärkende psychologische Effekte an der Stelle.
Na, ich bin da nicht so ganz sicher, ob man sich das wirklich alt damit erklären lässt.
Ja, alles nicht, aber es ist halt ein wichtiger Teil.
Also gerade diese Geschichte mit den geschlossenen Einheiten und der Aufbau und die Struktur dieser Einheiten und die Art und Weise, wie die eingesetzt und abgestellt werden, hat da auch eine ganze Menge mit zu tun. Und deshalb, wir sind weniger, die sind viele Effekte, negiert sich halt schon dadurch, dass die halt eben sich auf ihre Kollegen verlassen können, zumindest häufig. Und auch trainieren, sich auf die zu verlassen und zu wissen, dass die da draußen sind halt zwar mehr, aber die sind halt nicht so organisiert. Wie gesagt, manchmal gibt es halt diesen gegenteiligen Effekt, dass der Polizeiführer implizit davon ausgeht, dass die Demonstranten oder die Blockierenden strategisch vorgehen und ihre Truppenteile bewegen und......spielen Schach gegen jemanden, der überhaupt nicht Schach spielt. Genau, die fangen halt an, Taktik Schach zu spielen gegen Leute, die da einfach nur zufällig sich überlegen, oh da hinten ist gerade ein Lücke, lass mal hin rennen.
Ja, was für Einsatzmittel haben die denn jetzt im Detail? Das wollten wir noch ausführen.
Ja, also das wichtigste Einsatzmittel bei solchen Sachen ist natürlich immer der Knüppel. Der war früher halt ein Holzknüppel, mittlerweile halt eher ein Gummi- oder Plastikknüppel.
Ist das eigentlich weniger gefährlich?
Was?
Na, gehen da weniger Knochen bei zu Bruch, wenn es Gummi ist?
Naja, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Oder wiegt es weniger, warum haben sie denn es getauscht?
Ja, also ein Holzknüppel ist leichter und härter in der Regel und geht halt schneller zu Bruch. Und ein Gummi- bzw. Plastikgummi-Knüppel ist meistens schwerer und erzeugt auch durchaus heftigere Schmerzen so als ein Holzknüppel, führt aber wohl weniger häufig zum Schädelbruch oder so ähnlich.
Das ist ja super.
Haben sie zumindest gesagt. Aber das negiert sich halt alles, weil mittlerweile haben die eigentlich fast alle Tonfass im Einsatz. Das sind also diese Knüppel mit so einem Abzweig, auf ungefähr ein bisschen weniger als ein Viertel der Länge. Zuerst hast du den normalen Knüppel und dann geht er ungefähr da, wo deine Faust endet, wenn du ihn anfasst.
Wie beim Schwert damals.
Da geht noch mal so ein Ding zur Seite weg. Und wenn du den da anfasst, dann hast du den Knüppel längs deines Unterarms und da steht vorne noch so ein Stück vor. Mit diesem Stück warte du. Damit hast du halt viele Möglichkeiten des Einsatzes, die du sonst nicht hast. So einer davon ist, dass du nicht so mit gezücktem Knüppel durch die Gegend lässt, sondern du hast halt den Knüppel in der Hand und hältst den Arm seitlich von deinem Körper, sodass nicht sofort sichtbar ist.
Dann kannst du den ganzen Arm als Hebel einsetzen.
Dann kannst du halt zum einen den Knüppel um dieses Ding drehen, drausschwenken, also um den Steg, sodass du halt nochmal die gesamte Wucht von dem, und zwar so aus der...
Einmal im Kreis hauen.
Einmal im Kreis hauen. Du kannst Stoßbewegungen ausführen, bevorzugt halt auf die Nieren-Gegend, weil da tut es halt richtig doll weh und gibt halt auch schöne Blutergüsse. Und du kannst halt den halt auch verwenden bei festen Armen, um halt den Arm auf den Rücken zu drehen, und so weiter und so fort. Also dieser Mehrzweckeinsatz-Stock, Fox-Montal Tonfer genannt nach dem japanischen Schlagstock, wo das Ding halt herkommt, ist mittlerweile...
Ist das jetzt so ein Martial-Arts-Ding oder auch... Ist ja auch hart...
.ist mittlerweile halt so der Standard geworden. Und den gibt es halt auch in der Teleskop-Variante, wo halt der lange Teil dann halt eingeschoben werden kann, meistens bei den Civis. Und das ist halt so der mittlerweile der Standard. Und die Verletzungen, die man mit so was verursachen kann, sind halt schon echt übel. Und es ist halt auch zu beobachten, dass die Arterverletzungen sich seit dem Einsatz von diesen Dingern schon verändert hat. Also dass eben auch gerade so eine Hämatome, die halt auf diese Stoßbewegungen zurückzuführen sind, häufiger auftreten und Leute entsprechend länger außergefecht sind. Ja, dann gibt es halt die Schutzausrüstung. Eine persönliche Schutzausrüstung. Früher war es halt primär Helm und Schild. Da ganz früher war es Blechschild. Zu Ostenzeiten gab es halt noch so ein Blechschild mit einem Schlitz. Der wurde bald auch schwer und unhandlich.
Schiedsschorte.
Dann haben sie das irgendwann durch Plexi das Schild ersetzt. Und irgendwann haben sie die weggelassen und auf eine Körpervollpanzerung umgestellt. Und zwar ausgehend von so Rakbi-Panzerungen. Das ist lustigerweise auch der, wie sie eben herstelle. Die halt so, die stellen halt dann so Beinschienen aus Plaste her. Das ist halt so ein Wabenplaster und oben sind so ein Körperpanzer-Dings und Nackenschutz und Armschutz und so. Deshalb, die legen das halt so richtig an.
Aber es sieht nicht aus wie beim Football, wo da wirklich irgendwie mehrere Zentimeter Luft noch zu finden ist.
Ist genau so ein, also genau das selbe Prinzip, nur dass es halt ein bisschen enger anliegt, damit sie sich noch besser bewegen können. Und mehr Teile abgepolstert sind. Also das wird halt mit so Gurt angelegt. Meistens ziehen sie dann so einen weiten Overroll drüber. Das ist halt nicht zu sehen. Wenn es halt richtig fies aussehen wollen oder zu warm ist, dann tun sich die Körperpanzerungen außen hin. Und das sieht dann halt richtig aus wie die Stormtroopers. So, also gerade die schwarzen, die schwarze Variante davon sieht dann wirklich aus wie Stormtroopers. Interessanteste Teile sind noch, manche von denen haben ja Schutzwesten an, also Stich- und Schuss-Schutzwesten. Da fragt man sich dann, warum gehen die im Gottes Willen damit auf eine Demo? Also was ist irgendwie der Hintergrund davon?
Die Terroristen?
Naja, der interessante Punkt ist, dass die bei den meisten Landespolizeien es ist so, dass du diese Schutzwesten als persönliche Schutzausrüstung bekommen kannst. Aber dann musst du sie auch immer anziehen, weil sonst erlischt dein Versicherungsschutz. Also du kannst dir halt aussuchen, ob du sie nicht willst, weil du dafür nicht dauernd schwitzen musst oder nicht dauernd den schweren Scheiß mit dir rumschleppen musst, und zwar bei jedem Einsatz. Oder ziehst du halt an und bist dann halt besser geschützt, aber hast halt irgendwie, naja.
Was wiegt denn so eine Körperrüstung?
Na ja, gibt es Dutzende verschiedene Varianten. Also vielleicht können wir mal gucken, ob wir da mal einen Hersteller-Link da reintun. Also die leichte Körperpanzerung wiegt, glaube ich, so elf Kilo. Das ist so viel. Die Plastikram mit Helmen dann halt. Und es gibt halt auch Schwere, aber die wird halt in der Regel nicht bei Demos oder so eingesetzt. Das ist halt aber schon, das hat auch erklärt, warum die nicht gerne rennen. Und wenn es warm ist, ist es halt noch viel döver. Also es ist halt so, dass die, also was sie halt richtig hassen, sind Demos.
Deswegen stehen sie einmal rum, damit sie nicht durchrennen müssen, sondern damit halt die von der anderen Seite kommen können.
Und die, also was sie halt richtig hassen, sind Demonstrationen von Leuten, die halt irgendwie sportlich sind und halt einfach mal lange Strecken rennen. Da stehen sie so überhaupt nicht drauf, weil rennt sie so scheiße in diesen Ausrüstungen offensichtlich und wird dann halt auch richtig warm.
Es gibt noch so eine lustige Anekdote von dem Spezialeinsatzkommando bei der Festnahme, der Sauerland-Terroristen, wenn ihr euch erinnert. Und da gab es unter anderem am Rand die Geschichte, dass die kamen halt auch in ihren fetten Rüstungen da an und konnten die dann nicht verfolgen, weil es einfach zu schwer war, die Rüstungen. Die haben nämlich auch die schwere Variante gehabt, nicht die...
Die richtig fetten Schutz...
Richtig, und die konnten dann... Also die Terroristen, sag ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, die sind dann da über den Zaun gehüpft, ja. Und da ist ja nicht dran zu denken, wenn du in so einer schweren Monsterrüstung da langklappst. Und ja, das war sogar zu witzig, dass sie die... Jetzt haben sie dann halt aufgelistet, warum es eigentlich so schwierig war, die da zu verhaften und warum es jetzt so besonders ein großer Einsatz war. Das war alles echt super.
Tja. Ja, dann haben sie natürlich noch Tränengas, also hatten wir schon kurz erwähnt. Also in der Regel ist das halt CS-Gas. Die gibt's in verschiedenen Darreichungsformen. Also einmal als Spray sind halt meistens so kleine Sprühe, aber zugelassene sind auch größere, bis hin so zur Größe von kleinen Feuerlöschern.
Es gibt da noch einen Unterschied zwischen Tränengas und CS-Gas, oder ist das dasselbe?
CS-Gas ist das in Deutschland zugelassene Tränengas. Und früher gab's noch CN, das war dann klar, weil er nicht mehr zugelassen ist. Es gibt immer wieder Berichte, deren Glaubwürdigkeit ich nicht beurteilen kann, dass trotzdem noch alte CN-Bestände eingesetzt wurden, wenn sie kein CS mehr hatten. Aber das kann ich so nicht bestätigen, da sind wir jetzt nicht ohne Weiteres. In der Regel wird mittlerweile CS-Gas in Granatenform eingesetzt, sind halt so eine kleine Alu-Töpfe, sind so ungefähr so groß wie so eine Cola-Dose, ein bisschen kleiner, also groß wie eine kleine Cola-Dose, die werden in der Regel aus so kleinen Granatwerfer-Dingern verschossen. Also das ist im Hinterteil ein Pistolengriff mit einer Platzpatrone und die Grasladung davon schleudert halt dann vorne immer aus so einem dicken Lauf diese CS-Kartusche raus und die blubbert dann also vor sich hin und verbreitet halt diesen stechenden weißen Nebel, der halt auch so ganz spezifischen Geruch hat.
Ist denn eigentlich verboten, die zurückzuwerfen? Also wenn jetzt so was kommt und landet vor dir und du denkst dir so, hm, ich kann jetzt hier entweder leiden oder ich... Also es gibt ja so Bilder von, ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Demo ist, ich glaube Spanien, als dann einer mit dem Hockeyschläger da stand und das tatsächlich direkt zurückschossen hat. Super, super Aktion.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das verboten ist, ich glaube, dass dann meistens die Situation schon so weit eskaniert ist.
Und es ist auch egal, wenn die alle verhaftet werden.
CS wird halt auch noch beigemischt in Wasser werfern. Das ist halt besonders eklig, weil das dann halt brennt auf der ganzen Haut. Das ist also eine doch eine relativ widerliche Angelegenheit. Die Polizei hat in der Regel halt Gasmasken, also wenn du siehst, dass sie die Gasmasken aufsetzen, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass es dann halt in relativ naher Zeit Trinkgas eingesetzt wird. In jüngerer Zeit nehmen sie halt noch gerne Pfefferspray. Das ist also Kapsiakin oder Paver heißt die andere Variante, also P-A-V-A, sind die beiden in Deutschland zugelassene Varianten davon. Und das sind halt Moleküle, die sind direkt dazu designt, an den Schmerzrezeptoren der Augen anzudocken.
Oh prima.
Das ist halt das, was sie dir dann halt in die Augen sprühen. Und deine Augen schwirren halt sofort zu. Es tut halt so tierisch weh, dass du halt überhaupt nichts mehr anderes willst, außer weg und einen kalten Eimer Wasser.
Die Wasserwerfer-Beimischung ist legal in Deutschland. Hab ich ja erstaunlicherweise festgestellt.
Kann eingesetzt werden als Einsatz.
Können die einfach mal lustigerweise dementieren, sie das gerade noch in Stuttgart, obwohl das wohl so alle Zeugen sich im Grunde einig sind.
Also das ist halt sehr schwer zu sagen. Also häufig ist es halt auch so, wenn die Grasgranaten einsetzen danach Wasserwerfer, dass das ungefähr den selben Effekt hat, weil das Wasser halt aus der Luft genug zuerst mitreißt. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie das halt einfach eingesetzt haben. Also es ist halt so, dass in den Wasserwerfern sind diese Beimisch-Tanks drinnen und die werden da halt durchaus auch eingesetzt.
Der Operator drückt einen anderen Knopf oder wie?
Naja, muss der Kommandant freigeben.
Also das ist nicht beim Einfüllen des Wassers.
Nee, das ist eine Beimischung. Das ist ein Beimisch-Tank. Also diese, wie gesagt, das Pfefferspray gibt es halt auch in verschiedenen Darrechnungsgrößen. Also von so kleiner Dose, die halt so wie so eine kleinere Deodorose ist, bis hin zu irgendwie kleiner Feuerlöscher mit 400 Milliliter. Und das Wichtige ist, diese ganzen kleinen Sprühdinger haben eine gewisse Reichweite. Und dies bei den großen Dosen, also diesen 400 Milliliter Dosen, ist die so halt bis zu zehn Meter, also schon echt weit. Das heißt, wenn man am vorderen Rand der Demonstration steht und die diese Dinge auspacken, dann lohnt es also schon, den Weg nach hinten anzutreten. Das ist also doch eher unangenehm und die werden halt im gezielten Sprühstoß verwendet. Das heißt, es ist halt so, dass die kommen auch mit ordentlich Druck da raus. Und das muss man sich mehr so vorstellen wie eine Wasserpistole, wo das halt der Pfefferspray rauskommt. Das ist halt nicht ein Nebel, sondern ein gezielter Sprühstrahl.
Das kann man auch gut sehen auf den Videos.
Denen sie halt dann auf die Gesichter lenken und kommt halt auch gerne mal vor, dass man dann wirklich sindet, auf die Gesichter zu sprühen oder würdest du nicht lieber so eine Art Nebel haben? Nee, das halt in die Augen sprühen.
Aber du setzt es doch, wenn es ein gezielter Schuss ist, da hab ich mich mal gefragt, dann triffst du ja quasi nur die, die du direkt triffst, wenn du in so einer Art Parfum-Spray hättest, dann könntest du ja gleich die ganze Gegend sozusagen. Also ich sah immer so aus, als hätten die eigentlich das Ziel, irgendwie alle zu treffen, weil die so rumschwenken, aber dann hätte ich gedacht, nimmst du lieber so eine Art Nebel, der da auch alle trifft.
Nein, du brauchst halt schon eine gewisse Konzentration am Auge, dass das halt irgendwie funktioniert.
Also es würde nicht reichen, wenn ich dir quasi ans Kinn sprühe und das dann hoch...
Das ist halt schon unangenehm genug, weil deine Lippen natürlich auch irgendwie und so, aber was ich versuche, und das wird halt auch trainiert, halt genau mit so einem Schwenk einmal die Augen mitzunehmen. Und was halt dagegen hilft, ist viel Wasser. Es ist halt also alle anderen Sachen, die es da immer so gibt, mit Essig oder Zitronensäure oder Milch oder so, ist halt alles Bolschel. Das einzige, was wirklich hilft, ist kühlen, viel Wasser. Sowohl bei Trinkgas als auch bei Pfefferspray. Und das ist halt noch eine ganze Weile echt unangenehm. Also da kann man halt relativ wenig tun. Es gibt für Pfefferspray eine neutralisierende Substanz. Eines, gab es da eine Menge Snake Oil, also die wurde halt verkauft und dann wieder nicht verkauft. Und das war so ein bisschen...
Es gibt wohl Leute, die natürlich immun sind gegen CS-Gas.
Wenn du richtig betrunken bist, bist du gegen sowohl, also kannst du Glück haben und sowohl gegen CS als auch gegen Pfefferspray immun sein.
Das habe ich empfehlenswert, weil es an sich schon ein Grund ist, warum die Polizei dich rausgreift.
Also du musst... Da hilft es halt nicht, einen Wodka zu trinken, sondern das meint halt schon ernsthaft betrunken. Dann gibt es halt Fälle, wo du halt... Ich kann es ja nicht drauf verlassen, dass es so ist. Aber es ist halt so, dass es wohl einen nennenswerten freistelligen Anteil der Bevölkerung gibt, der, wenn er richtig betrunken ist, immun gegen Pfeffer oder CS oder beides ist.
Was ist denn die Idee dahinter, in so eine Menschenmasse CS-Gas reinzusprühen? Kann da nicht irgendwie ein Stampede entstehen, wenn die Leute dann irgendwie sich gegenseitig tot trampeln?
Das kann passieren, das ist auch schon passiert, ja.
Na, ist das nicht jemand? Warum machen die das denn nicht?
Um die Leute zu vertreiben.
Na, kannst du da nicht irgendwie laut ACDC spielen oder so? Keine Ahnung. Ich meine, etwas weniger Invasives, als ich meine, das erscheint mir einfach sehr gefährlich.
Das ist doch gefährlich. Also es gibt da regelmäßig auch ernsthafte Verletzungen bei. Also es gibt auch Leute zum Beispiel, die Asthma haben. Für die ist ein Trägenas-Einsatz halt tatsächlich lebensbedrohlich angelegen. Und für die stellt sich halt tatsächlich dann die Frage, wenn sie auf Demonstrationen gehen, die halt möglicherweise nicht friedlich enden, ob es denn da möglicherweise zu solchen Folgen kommt, die ihr Leben bedrohen, wenn Trägenas eingesetzt wird.
Wobei auch mein Auge verlieren wie jetzt hier bei S21 ist ja auch eine Sache, die man eigentlich nicht hat.
Wasserwerfer ist halt genau so ein Ding. Also man sieht das ja immer nur so im Fernsehen und macht sich nicht so richtig eine Vorstellung davon.
Wie viel Druck da eigentlich ist, ne?
Wie viel Druck dahinter ist. Also es gibt regelmäßig bei Wasserwerfer Einsätzen, wenn die direkt auf die Leute gerichtet werden, Rippenbrüche. Das ist ja so die üblichste Verletzung nach Augenverletzung. Bei Wasserwerfer Einsätzen sind Rippenbrüche.
Ach so scheiße. Also es ist wie ein Fauststack nur stärker.
Ja, das ist also richtig doll. Und die können auch mal den Wikipedia zu den aktuellen deutschen Wasserwerfernlern reintun. Das sind halt richtig zweistellige Barzahlen, die da mit dem da der Wasserdruck rauskommt. Also es ist halt so klar.
Womit man dann sonst einen Hausfassaden reinigt.
Ja, das ist halt so, also es ist tatsächlich so kercherartig, nur halt mit sehr viel mehr Wasser. Der Druck, der da entsteht. Dementsprechend sehen halt auch die Verletzungen aus. Und es ist nicht nur so, dass jetzt mal machen, mal ein bisschen sprühen, damit die da alle nass werden und keine Lust mehr haben nach Hause gehen.
Das ist nicht eine Angriffswaffe.
Das können sie halt auch tun. Sondern es ist halt richtig eine Angriffswaffe, die halt mehr Gewalt ausübt als ein Schlagstock. Und gibt halt, also gerade bei den Augenverletzungen, gibt es halt auch noch eine Menge zum Beispiel, die da hinschneiden, dass die, wenn sie vor den, direkt vor die Füße der Demonstranten sprühen, dass dann der Dreck hochgeschleudert wird vom Fußboden durch den Druck. Also wenn du halt beim Kercher irgendwie deine Terrasse sauber machst, wird ja auch der ganze Dreck hochgeschleudert.
Wieso machen die denn überhaupt auf Augenhöhe mit so einem Wasserwerfer, wenn du das auch nicht verlieren kannst?
Das ist halt schwer zu steuern, weil du siehst halt...
Weil die Teile auf dem Dach montiert sind von dem Auto.
Naja, die haben schon, also die üben natürlich, das Ding zu benutzen, aber das ist halt auch nicht so häufig. Und wenn du aus dem Winkel guckst, wie halt diese Kanone ist, dann hast du ja Reihen von Demonstranten hintereinander und du willst die ja wegscheuchen. Und dann hältst du die halt mit dem Strahl rein und versuchst die halt wegzupusten. Und das ist halt wirklich, also wenn du immer so ein Video siehst aus so einer Wasserwerfer-Bordkamera, das halt schiebt das wirklich die Leute beiseite.
Also die gab es übrigens gerade zu sehen bei der Polizeipressekonferenz zur S21. Ich habe sie so ein Video gezeigt aus dem Cockpit von dem, nee nicht aus, sondern knapp außerhalb des Cockpits. Das ist irgendwie die Einsatzkamera von dem Wasserwerfer. Kommt nun gut sehen. Eigentlich ist das Teil ja dahin gefahren worden, damit er vor sich die Straße leer macht. Aber die haben halt so seitwärts in die Menge gefeuert. Gibt es da irgendeinen taktischen Grund für? Oder war das nur einfach, wir hauen jetzt?
Das ist reiner Terror. Also ich finde Wasserwerfer-Einsatz persönlich auch nicht zu rechtfertigen, weil es halt einfach so eine brutale Waffe ist. Und es ist jetzt so, dass der neue Wasserwerfer, den jetzt die deutschen Polizei kriegen sollen, der Wasserwerfer 10.000, also momentan hast du die Wasserwerfer 9.000, hat 9.000 Liter Tank, der Wasserwerfer 10.000, hat 10.000 Liter Tank.
Klingt so ein bisschen BFG 9.000.
Ja, genau. Der hat dann noch andere Einsatzmodi, also der hat dann so ein Hohlstrahlrohr, mit dem du dann halt auch einfach mal so Wasser, also mit doll regnen lassen kannst oder so.
Was mir persönlich ja schon unangenehm genug wäre, muss ich sagen, so irgendwie da.
Und sie halt auch solche Sachen, da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das aussieht, eine sogenannte Wasserwand machen können sollen. Ich bin mal gespannt. Wahrscheinlich wollen sie dann die Wasserwand anschalten und dann langsam vorfahren oder so, weiß ich nicht genau. Also wird jedenfalls, wird da massiv aufgerüstet. Also diese Wasserwärfer sind halt schon so ziemlich mit das Fetteste, was sie haben. Also sie haben halt noch Räumenpanzer. Das sind halt so kleine militärische Radpanzerfahrzeuge, die zum Barrikaden wegschieben gedacht sind. Also sie haben meistens vorne so ein Schubschild dran, um Barrikaden wegzuschieben. Die Wasserwärfer sind halt auch gepanzert. Also die sollen dazu dienen, dass man da auch die nicht ohne weiteres angreifen kann.
Ja, wie ist es denn nicht, wenn man so ein Wasserwerfer angreifen würde? Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, wenn es da wirklich mal so eine kriegsähnliche Zustände gibt, mit irgendwie Zwillen und was weiß ich, wenn man jetzt irgendwie so ein Wasserwerfer angreift, das kann ja keine Glasscheibe sein eigentlich, weil sonst splittert die und dann siehst du nichts mehr.
Das ist Plexiglas.
Relaxant.
Und wenn da irgendwie jemand sich Farbe gegensprüht oder so?
Na die haben ziemlich massive Scheibenwaschanlagen und auch große Scheibenwische. Das kann man sich mal angucken, wenn mal wieder beim BGS z.B. Bundespolizei oder bei der Landespolizei Tagtor auf einer Tür ist, dann fahren sie die Dinge auch gerne mal raus aus der Garage und dann kann man sich die angucken.
Ach nee, dann musst du ja mal eine Gig-Tour machen.
Das ist sehr instruktiv. Aber man muss eigentlich dann zusehen, dass man irgendwie sehr bürgerlich und diversen Demonstranten so ist.
Und CDU-Wähler aussieht ja.
Mal die CDU-Wähler-Verklärung belegen und dann erklären die auch gerne mal so. Also wie so ein Wasser funktioniert. Und dann kann man da auch mal in sich in die Kuppel setzen. Das ist so, dass die bei den modernen, das ist halt auch so, dass die Sitze sich mitdrehen mit dem Strahlrohr. Der guckt automatisch in die Richtung von Strahlrohr.
Das ist wie bei Star Wars, oder? So in dem Laser turret. Krass. Ich meine, gegen was haben die denn da so als Feindbild irgendwie? Haben die sich auch überlegt, wenn da irgendwie ein Chemiker kommt und ihnen da irgendwie Lösungsmittel raufkippt und dann, keine Ahnung?
Na ja, also dann machen sie halt ihre Scheibenspülanlage an. Allerdings ist es, also wie groß diese Effizienz davon ist, ist halt umstritten. Also es gibt da Berichte, dass tatsächlich Wasserwerfer abgezogen werden mussten, weil irgendjemand offensichtlich die richtige Farbelösungsmittel kombinatioll gefunden hat. Keine Ahnung.
Haben die Reifen?
Ja, aber die haben ein Notlaufsystema und irgendwie solche Sachen. Also gibt es gibt ein paar Fälle, wo Wasserwerfer erfolgreich angegriffen wurden, aber das war halt irgendwie so, dann immer jeweils die krasseren Geschichten.
Die Berufsdemonstranten.
Die viel Beschworneten. Hat dann auch nicht mehr viel mit Demonstrationen zu tun. Das sind schon eher Bürgerkriegsähnliche Auseinandersetzungen.
Ja, aber es ist doch erstaunlich, was die da für ein Technikniveau auffahren, wenn es um Schülerdemo geht.
Ja, also jetzt hier gerade dieser neue Wasserwerfer 10.000, da gab es so ein Detail, dass einer der Tests, mit dem die getestet wurde, war eine Gehwegplatte aus dem 5. Stock auf das Ding zu werfen.
Doch, krass, von oben, ja?
Von oben. Und Splitter. Und das ist etwas, was tatsächlich an der Mainzer Straße passiert sein soll. Also wo halt einfach, woher denn dieser Test, wo halt auch den Namen Mainzer-Straße-Test haben soll. Und, hat es überlebt? Also ich weiß nur, dass es Fotos hinterher gab von der Mainzer Straße, wo Gehwegplattenhochkanten in Polizeifahrzeugen so oben drin steckten. So halt diese kleinen.
Ja, aber darauf sind die Modernen jetzt ausgelegt, dass sie das aushalten. Da brauchst du ja echt irgendwie einen Atomschlag aus dem Orbit, um die Dinger loszurehnen oder wie?
Ja, naja, ich weiß nicht genau, aber es sind halt schon einfach so quasi militärische Technologie, die ja versinkt wurde. Ja gut.
Na was darf man denn damit jetzt machen? Also jetzt nehmen wir mal an, du stehst vor so einer Menge von Leuten, da einfach rauffeuern ist legal, wenn das so eine krasse Waffe ist.
Oder nur, wenn die vorher angeordnet ist. Also in der Regel ist es so, die sagen halt, okay, bitte verlassen Sie diese Straße, wir geben sich in den Bereich polizeilicher Maßnahmen. So und das sagen sie halt dreimal an.
Und wer da nicht weg ist, ist freiwillig.
Genau, so funktioniert das. Also wenn du halt, also wenn du halt, dann wird dann halt angesagt. Also in der Regel ist es so, dass die, wenn genug Presse da ist, dann lassen sie auch genügend Abstand dazwischen. Also sagen sie es noch mal an, noch mal an. Also sagen jetzt die letzte Aufforderung, jetzt legen wir gleich los. Wenn nicht so viel Presse da ist, dann können die drei Aufforderungen noch gerne in einem halben von 30 Sekunden passieren.
Wie ist es denn, wenn die Leute sich da irgendwie festgekesselt haben oder so? Das gibt es ja gelinkelig irgendwie an Bäumen oder an Türen oder Toren oder so und die gar nicht weg können? Können die dann trotzdem mit dem Wasserwerfer beschossen werden oder kommt das?
Das wird dann halt schon phasenweise sehr unangenehm, ja. Also es ist halt schon, es passiert halt schon. Also gerade so in Brockdorf und so, so was auch passiert. Und also auch die, was wir jetzt hier in Stuttgart zu sehen, war dieses Video, was so außer, als wenn sie auf Leute in den Bäumen mit den Wasserwerfern vorgegangen sind, ist ihnen eigentlich in Brockdorf verboten worden, weil natürlich die Leute halt einfach runterfallen können und sich dabei, also dabei umkommen können schlicht, wenn sie aus den Bäumen fallen. Da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher, was jetzt mit diesem Video war.
Wir haben noch eine Mail gekriegt von einem, der hat gesagt, der hat auf dem Baum mitdemonstriert und das sah nur so aus, zwischen den Bäumen durch auf die Menge geschossen. Was ich auch schon hart genug finde.
Ja, aber gut, deshalb, wie gesagt, Leute aus Bäumen schießen, ist ihnen irgendwann mal explizit verboten worden, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass sie sich daran halten müssen.
Woran erkennt man denn Leute, die auf einer Demo waren und von so einem, wir haben schon gesagt, Rippenbrüche. Andere typische Verletzungen sind...
Eine Augenverletzung ist der Klassiker, Abschürfungen von irgendwie vom Hingeschmissen werden. Also typischerweise sind halt eine Menge so eine Rempelverletzung. Also wird einfach umgeschubst, umgeschmissen werden von durchrennenden Polizisten. Kopfplatzwunden gibt es halt auch zu Genüge. Also wenn Leute halt einfach einen Knüppel auf den Kopf bekommen oder auch mal von Steinen, die von weiter hinten geworfen werden, ist halt durchaus üblich. Nasendjochbeinbrüche sind gerade durch Knüppel oder wie Knie oder Fäuste halt durchaus sehr üblich. Also die ist nicht so, dass die Polizei immer im Knüppel zuhört. Die haben auch gerne mal irgendwie dicke Handschuhe an oder Quarzhandhandschuhe an. Blutergösse sind üblich.
Wie funktionieren denn diese Handschuhe?
Diese Quarzhandhandschuhe? Na die sind ja...
Irgendwie der Sand ist flexibel, bis zu die Faust ballst, irgendwie sowas. Und dann ist es wie so ein Beton.
Dann ist der Raum rings um ihn so abgeschlossen, dass es hart wie ein Stein wird und sehr viel schwerer ist. Und die gesamte Energie am Ende des Faustschlags landet.
Ich hab ja mal so eine lustige Geschichte gelesen über die Geschichte vom Boxen, wo man als Laie denkt, diese Handschuhe, dass die abfedern und dass da die schweren Verletzungen zurückgehen. Aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Als die angefangen haben, diese gepolsterten Handschuhe zu verbreiten, dann hast du mehr Polsterung zwischen dir und dem Ding. Dann tut dir selbst als Schlager der Schlag nicht so weh. Und es gibt eine krasse Steigerung an Verletzungen. Die ersten Toten gab es überhaupt erst, nachdem diese Handschuhe eingeführt wurden. Das ist auch mal interessant.
Aha, okay. Also diese Quarzlandhandschuhe sind ja, zählen natürlich nicht zugelassene Einsatzmitteln. Also da gab es ja in Berlin auch mal wieder...
Weil das auch vom Bundesland abhängig, ne?
Nee. Nicht?
Also eigentlich ist ja Polizei bundeslandabhängig.
Ja, aber ich wüsste nicht, dass in irgendeinem Bundesland Quarzlandhandschuhe zugelassen sind. Es kann sein, dass das SEKs möglicherweise dürfen oder dass die GSG 9 nicht darf, aber so normale Einsatzhunderschaften wäre mir neu. Also wenn dann ein Leser bzw. ein Hörer was andere weiß, wären wir natürlich daran ein Hinweis interessiert. Also auch nicht zugelassen sind halt hier sowas wie Gummigeschosse und Gummischrot und sowas, was man so aus Nord-Urland und Südafrika kennt. Also Distanzwaffen, wo halt auch die Leute...
Na auch in Amerika gibt es ja sogar so...
Oder in Schweiz zum Beispiel.
Reality-TV-Serien, wo einem richtig übel wird, wo der Sheriff dann mal demonstriert, was er da...
Im Arsenal hat.
Genau, das sind die Non-Lethal-Weapons. Danach könnt ihr ja mal auf YouTube gucken oder so.
Zum Beispiel in der Schweiz ist halt Gumm...
Diese Beanbag-Teile, die sehen auch richtig böse aus. Da kriegste das sieht aus, als wenn so ein Rambock dich irgendwie...
Niederreicht, ja.
Niederberettert, ja. Also richtig böse.
Also in der Schweiz zum Beispiel sind Gummigeschosse zugelassen. Also Gummischrot zugelassen. Das sind dann halt so...
Gummischrot? Wie funktioniert das denn?
Das sind also Teile... Also die Fotos, die ich gesehen habe, waren so Zuckerwürfel, große Gummistöcke.
Aber das ist schon ein... Kein nicht wirklich Schrot, sondern nur von der Größe wie so ein Schrot. Schon ein zusammenhängender Block, oder nicht?
Naja, es sind halt so viele kleine Blöcke.
Na, das ist ja den Christins Auge und bist blind. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das kann ja in der Schweiz tatsächlich zugelassen sein. Also die hinterlassen halt auch ernsthafte... Also total richtig...
Oh, wie die Blutungen auch, ne? Ja, die kleinen Blöcke.
Also sind halt so ungefähr so groß wie ein Zuckerwürfel etwa.
Ich find's doch.
Und sind natürlich auch beliebte Sammlerobjekte nach Demonstrationen in Zürich, denn... Souvenir! Na die Sache, also was wir halt z.B. in der Mainzer Straße beobachtet haben, war, da die ja keine Gunnigeschüsse verwenden durften, was sie getan haben, war, die haben sich halt mit Gafferband ihre starken Taschenlampen oben auf die Graskranatenwerfer draufgetapet und haben dann einen gezielten Schuss mit den Graskranaten auf die Leute geschossen.
Und wie mein... Ach, damit sie im Dunkel schießen können oder was?
Ja klar, damit sie zielen können. Das ist halt sozusagen wie ein Laser. Da haben sie halt die Taschenlampe benutzt und haben gezielt mit den Graskranaten. Also da gab es auch etliche Leute, die echt üble Verwundungen, vor allem weil diese Graskranaten noch heiß sind. Also da hast du halt nicht nur den Einschlag, sondern auch deine Klamotten.
Na und die wiegen auch was, wenn du die an den Kopf kriegst. Das ist auch erstmal...
Also das ist halt schon ziemlich heftig. Also dabei helfen die sich gerne mal mit so Sachen, die dann unter dem Radar sind. Ja, na dementsprechend kann man eigentlich sagen, dieses Gewaltmonopol muss halt in jedem Fall kontrolliert werden. Also lohnt sich halt auch dringend hinzugucken. Wir fahren da schon seit einer ganzen Weile, dass die...
Ach du, man Taser hatten wir noch nicht, ne?
Taser hatten wir noch nicht. Ja gut, Taser sind in Deutschland... Sind auch nicht zugelassen... .nur für SEKs zugelassen momentan. Also halt als Einsatzmittel, was es sich bei irgendwelchen Entführungen oder sowas... Also es gibt eigentlich auch Bestrebungen, für normale Polizei zuzulassen.
Da sind auch schon Leute dran gestorben. Also richtig ernstzunehmend viele.
Viele, ja. Aber das sind Diskussionen, die jeweils in den Bundesländern stattfinden. Da gibt es halt einige, die ja weiter vorpreschen, andere, wo halt nicht so ist. Ich erwarte schon, dass das auch hierher kommen wird mit dem Taser. Ja, ein Grund mehr, Gewaltmonopol muss kontrolliert werden. Also klar ist halt, man braucht halt eine Kennzeichnungspflicht. Also kann nicht sein, dass Leute, die über ein derartiges Arsenal verfügen und halt der politischen Weisung unterworfen sind, dieses Arsenal einzusetzen, ohne Kennzeichnung rumlaufen. Das geht nicht. Also von mir kann es Nummern sein, oder was auch immer. Aber klar ist halt, die Leute müssen identifizierbar sein, um im Zweifel für den Einsatz des Gewaltmonopols, das wir an sie delegiert haben als Bevölkerung, zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden zu können.
Na, und überhaupt muss man sie zur Rechenschaft ziehen können. Es gibt ja genug Fälle, wo die identifiziert sind, aber trotzdem nichts passiert ist, weil dann heißt es eben, das war gerechtfertigt. Alles, was die sagen müssen, damit es ein gerechtfertigter Einsatz war, ist, dass du gewaltbereit aussahst. Und quasi sie sich mit Selbstverteidigung, bla. Und das Problem ist auch, wenn ein Polizist dich angreift und die landet dann vor Gericht, die Sache, dann glaubt man dem Polizisten schon deswegen, also du bist Angeklagter an der Stelle, du hast prinzipiell alles erstmal eine Schutzbehauptung, was du vorbringst. Aber es ist auch so, dass der weil einfach ein Beamter ist, der Polizist schon per se, wenn der irgendwas beobachtet und das zu den Akten gibt, dann ist es viel glaubvertrauenswürdiger, glaubwürdiger, als wenn ich irgendwas zu meiner Verteidigung vorzubringen habe. Also das ist auch noch so eine Sache, die eigentlich wo man was gegen tun müsste.
Hoffiger passiert es auch bei Zivilpolizei im normalen.
Na und die denken sich natürlich gegenseitig, das hatten wir auch schon, aber per se ist so eine Aussage von Polizisten deutlich vertrauenswürdiger vor Gericht, als die Aussage des sich verteidigenden Angeklagten.
Ja, also zumindest wurde in der Regel so gehandhabt. Also passiert halt häufig auch mal, dass Zivilpolizisten, die halt über jemand herfallen und den halt echt übel, hart verhaften und dann auch nicht mal sagen, dass sie Zivilpolizisten sind. Es gibt eine Menge Fälle von Leuten, die dachten, sie wären schlicht überfallend entführt. Weil teilweise halt einfach aussieht wie im Fernsehen. Da sind halt so ein paar Leute im Räuber Zivil. Die springen aus dem Auto raus, reißen jemanden nieder, hauen ihn und schlagen ihn und ziehen in das Auto. Und da gibt es halt auch schon mal Fälle, wo dann halt ganz normale, wie immer es doch war, CDU-Wähler denken, sie beobachten da gerade einen schwer kriminellen Akt und wollen eingreifen und kriegen ihn auch noch auf die Fasse. Also das passiert halt durchaus auch schon mal.
Genau so einen Fall hab ich neulich gehabt in der Bekanntschaft.
Ja, also es ist halt nicht so, dass es halt ein theoretisches Risiko ist.
Das ist auch so ein Problem, wenn man denkt. Völlig klar, ich bin hier gerade misshandelt worden. Ich hab drei Zeugen. Das ist nicht offen.
Vorhin schon, ja.
Da muss man dann auch mit Repessalienrechnen als Zeuge, wenn man für sowas zur Verfügung steht. Das ist einfach zivilcourage tatsächlich, die man da aufbringen muss. Leider. Ja, wir wollen ein bisschen dazu übergehen, was denn eigentlich das richtige Verhalten auf Demos ist, was man alles nicht machen darf, weil man sonst quasi einen Vorwand bietet. Um verprügelt zu werden von der Polizei.
Ja, es gibt halt in der Datenschleuderausgabe 94, die wir auch verlinkt haben als PDF, einen Demo Grundregeln für Nerds Ratgeber, wo halt das allgemeine Verhalten auf Demonstrationen ein wenig erläutert wird, um sicherzustellen, dass man da seiner politischen Meinungsäußerung nachgehen kann, ohne Gefahr zu laufen, da misshandelt zu werden. Es gibt halt einige Sachen, die sind halt per se verboten, zum Beispiel vermunkt und so.
Was übrigens auch in Alleingang Deutschlands ist, in anderen Ländern völlig normal, dass man vermummt zu demos gehen muss.
Ja, abhängig von den Ländern, aber ja.
Ja, sich sagen, Frankreich zum Beispiel, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, eines der Kernkonzepte dabei ist, das ist auch ein Konzept der Passivbewaffnung. Also wo der Staat sagt, das ist eine Rüstung. Du als Blöde.
Das wird benutzt, das hast du nur dabei, um dich dagegen zu wehren, dass die Polizei dich in ihrem Beruf belangt.
Die Rechtslogik ist, mit einer sogenannten Passivbewaffnung, sei es eine Vermurmung, die deine Reifikation verhindert oder mit einem dicken Klamotten oder Lederjacke oder Handschuhen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr oder gar ein Helm oder Stahlkappenschuhe, die trägst du, um zu verhindern, dass der Staat im Zweifel sein Gewaltmonopol ausüben kann, um dich an einem Unrecht zu hindern. Und so kommen dann halt alle Sachen zusammen.
Eine Menge Potenzial dabei für meinen Geschmack. Aber in der Praxis wie gesagt Stahlkappenschuhe, wo ich persönlich schon mir nicht klar ist, was ich damit behindere. Wollten die mir auf den Fuß treten oder was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Totaler Blödsinn. Aber also das geht ja noch weiter. Es ist zum Beispiel Motorradfahrer tragen ja normalerweise so ein Lederkleidung und ein Helm. Und der Helm ist Vermummung.
Und Passivbewaffnung.
Ja und Passivbewaffnung, weil es den Schlagstock aufhält. Und die Lederkleidung gilt auch als Passivbewaffnung, weil die eben Schläge abfedert, was ja genau die Idee ist dabei. Aber das heißt, dass quasi Motorradfahrer ausgeschlossen sind, außer sie haben einen Koffer dabei mit Zweitkleidung. Ja, ein von ihrem Demonstrationsrecht gebraucht zu machen, das ist ja schon hart eigentlich. Tja, was gibt es noch? Polizisten anfassen ist generell eine schlechte Idee. Auch nicht umarmen, auch nicht, wenn man ganz friedlich aussieht und den Blumen ansteckt, selbst das kann nicht ausgelegt werden.
Also Blumen nur überreichen, nicht anstecken.
Und Clownskostüme kommen auch nicht gut an. Haben wir Erfahrungen bei Heiligendamm sammeln können. Da gab es diese Clowns-Army. Und die haben Wasserpistolen dabei gehabt. Und das ist ihnen ausgelegt worden, als da Säure drin sei.
Ja, das haben sie tatsächlich dann unter den Polizisten verbreitet, dass da Polizeibeamte mit Säure angegriffen worden seien. Und dann gab es tatsächlich auch entsprechende Reaktionen. Als sie dann mit Wasser beschossen wurden, dachten die wirklich, da ist Säure drin.
Da gibt es auch Polizeifotos in der Presse vorhin, wie die richtig zurückgeschreckt sind, weil sie dachten, sie werden jetzt mit Säure besprüht.
Und der Hintergrund ist, dass die Clowns-Army, was die ja tut, ist, die parodiert der Polizei. Dass die stellen sich daneben und machen die Bewegungen nach und so und das nervt die natürlich unglaublich.
Natürlich ist da die Idee dabei.
Das nervt die halt in einer Art und Weise, dass als Clown mittlerweile verkleidet zu gehen, zu einer Demo ist eigentlich ein sicheres Rezept, noch in einer dunklen Ecke noch einen Knüppel über den Kopf zu bekommen, wenn sich die Gelegenheit bietet. Das ist halt selbst wenn man sonst nichts tut. Fotos von Polizisten machen ist so eine Sache, sollte man tatsächlich tun, wenn man Gewalt beobachtet. So sollte man tatsächlich filmen und fotografieren. Aber sich darüber im Klaren sein, dass man sich damit auch zum Ziel machen kann. Wenn man nicht nur einmal macht, ist scheiße.
Aber wenn du 200 machen, da gab es halt auf der Freiheit statt Angst-Demo so eine Szene, die ist mir zugetragen worden, wie die Polizisten gerade versucht haben, so einen Übergriff zu machen. Und dann plötzlich haben die um sie herum so einen Kreis von Nerds mitgezückten Kameras. Und alle haben ihre Kamerafunktion aktiviert. Und dann haben sie dann doch lieber sehr vorsichtig verhaftet. Das war wohl die vorkommendste und freundlichste Verhaftung, die je stattgefunden hat.
Verstehe.
Aber wenn es nur einer macht, dann kommen die halt gerne mal und beschlagnahmen dann eine SD-Karte und so Sachen.
Wegen all möglichen Ausreden, Persönlichkeitsrecht der Beamten zum Beispiel.
Was natürlich totaler Blödsinn ist. Also das stimmt natürlich, aber deswegen dürfen sie die eigentlich nicht die SD-Karte wegnehmen. Ja, ich darf ja auch nicht rumlaufen und den Polizisten die SD-Karte wegnehmen, weil sie die da rumfilmen. Also im Zweifelsfall muss das halt, wenn es da Einspruch gibt, muss halt vor Gericht irgendwie geklärt werden, wer da im Recht war. Aber das ist ja kein Grund, irgendwie den Leuten die Karte wegzunehmen.
Ja, naja, so was mit der Karte wegnehmen ist ja noch relativ harmlos. Also ich habe ja zum Beispiel...
Ja, es gibt auch wo die Kamera dann irgendwie...
Also ich habe noch ein Foto, wo man ein ziemlich verzerrtes Polizistengesicht im Hintergrund sieht. Davor einen schwarzen Strich, das ist der Gummiknüppel.
Der in deine Richtung kam gerade.
Eine Zehntel Sekunde bevor er auf meinem Objektiv einschlug. Krass, was ist das? Das war eigentlich schon 1993 oder so.
Also da macht man sich keine Freude mit.
Also genauso wenig Nachnamen und Dienstnummer fragen.
Eigentlich die selbstverständlichste Sache der Welt, oder? Ich meine schließlich sind das ja unsere Angestellten.
Also nach Namen und Dienstnummer fragen sollte man nur tun, wenn genügend Leute dabei sind, die filmen. Damit man sich erstellt, dass man dann nicht...
Und selbst dann kann man auf die Fresse kriegen, wie wir bei der vorigen Freistaatangstdemo gesehen haben.
Ja, Glasflaschen mitnehmen ist verboten. Gut aus offensichtlichen Gründen können geworfen werden, können später benutzt werden. Also kann ich irgendwie halbwegs...
Als Angriffswaffe, das ist ja auch noch nachvollziehbar. Das trifft uns natürlich hart, weil in unserem Umfeld immer die Mate...
Ja, die muss man in einem Plastiflaschen anführen. Fahrräder werden gelegentlich als Blockademittel bezeichnet, aber das habe ich in der Praxis extrem selten erlebt. Also ich bin häufiger mit Fahrrad- auf Demonstration unterwegs und bisher hatte ich dann ein, zwei Mal, dass sie gesagt haben, hier geht es nicht lang, ihr dürft nicht fahren oder schieben sie mal oder so, aber jetzt bisher noch keiner...
Ja, also auch wenn du schiebst, also das war einer der Gründe, den sie vorgebracht haben, gegen den Titel, den sie verprügelt haben, gesagt haben, der habe sein Fahrrad als Blockademittel dabei gehabt. Und man muss ja sagen, das ist wirklich ein bisschen unhaltlich, wenn man durch so eine dichte Menschenmenge mit seinem Fahrrad schiebt. Das ist...
Ja, man sucht sich dann halt eine Lücke oder so.
Ja, das geht schon, aber es ist halt vielleicht irgendwie einfach anschließend irgendwo und gut ist. Außer man ist halt in einer Großstadt, wo gerne mal Fahrräder geklaut werden. Tja, rumbrüllen ist auch eine schlechte Idee. Bedrohliche Körperhaltung haben, da gibt es dann gerne mal Vorwärtsverteidigung seitens der Polizei und man fängt sich ein bisschen Prügel ein. Beleidigung gegen Polizisten, auch immer wieder ein Klassiker, das ist generell nicht so schlau.
Ja, also beim Beleidigen von Beamten ist ganz wichtig, niemals die persönlich zu beleidigen.
Sonst immer die Polizei insgesamt.
Also es gilt auch tatsächlich, auch zum Beispiel in den USA, dass es nicht verboten ist, über das System zu schimpfen, aber die einzelnen Beamten persönlich zu beleidigen, ist tatsächlich verboten. Da muss man also sehr sorgfältig schimpfen. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Nicht im Effekt schimpfen. Ja, es gibt noch Leute, die haben gedacht, wenn sie da die Polizeikamera-Crew auffahren sehen und die da breiträumig die Bevölkerung filmen, dass sie sich einen Spaß machen und die moonen. Also Hose runter und den nackten Arsch zeigen in die Kamera und das geht auch nach hinten los. Also alles, was sie als Vorwand benutzen können, um es gegen dich zu verwenden, wird im Zweifelsfall auch gegen dich verwendet.
Ja, Platzverweisen nicht nachkommen, ist dann halt dieser Klassiker, mit dem sie berufsbegehend sind.
Das wird auch generell behauptet, dass sie dann die haben.
Wieso?
Wir haben ihnen doch drei Platzverweise ausgesprochen und sie sind nicht gegangen. Da ist es immer schwer zu beweisen am Ende. Deswegen, im Zweifelsfall werden sie das wahrscheinlich sagen, dass sie Platzverweise ausgesprochen haben. Eine Sache, die mir immer noch aufgefallen ist, dass es gelegentlich so Fälle gibt, zum Beispiel bei der militanten Gruppe, da hieß es dann, die haben Bundeswehrfahrzeuge angezündet und der Staatsschutz ermittelt jetzt. Und es klingt ja, jetzt kommt hier irgendwie die geheime Polizei irgendwas. Was hat es denn damit auf sich?
Der Staatsschutz ist halt die Abteilung der Kriminalpolizei, die sich um Straftaten mit politischer Motivation kümmert oder Straftaten, bei denen es einen klaren politischen Kontext gibt.
Das sind aber schon normale Polizisten. Oder sind es irgendwie Elite-Einheiten, besondere Behörde?
Es ist halt so, es ist halt eine Abteilung der Kriminalpolizei. In der Regel treten die halt in zivil auf. Also eigentlich immer, es ist keine Schutzpolizei, nur Schutzpolizei ist noch uniformiert. Es ermitteln halt eben in zivil, sind halt auch zivile Veranstaltungen unterwegs. Und die haben natürlich schon relativ weitgehende Befugnisse. Das heißt also, die können halt irgendwie auch observieren und dergleichen Dinge tun. Und der Staatsschutz hat zumindest bei den meisten Staatsschutzdelikten, eben dadurch, dass die Delikte mit einer so hohen Strafe belegt sind, auch mehr Rechte. Also zumindest in weiten Teilen des Strafgesetzbuches die Ermittlungskompetenzen sich nach der zu erwartenden Strafe ungefähr richtet. Das heißt also, wenn es über drei Jahre Knast geht, dann dürfen sie plötzlich mehr. Gibt Fälle, wo es überhaupt nicht so ist.
Also wenn ich jetzt dein Auto anzünde, dann ermittle ich normale Polizei, aber wenn es ein Bundeswehrauto ist, dann kommt der Staatsschutz oder wie?
Beziehungsweise wenn ich sage, du hast mein Auto angezündet, weil du CDU-Wähler bist. Also wenn du z.B. nehmst einen CDU-Wahlkampfbus an, dann ist das politische Kriminalität, das ist ganz klar. Das ermittelt halt der Staatsschutz und der hat dann durchaus weitergehende Ermittlungskompetenzen. Typischerweise soll sich der Staatsschutz um solche Sachen, also um die echten Staatsschutzdelikte kümmern, z.B. Friedensverrat, Hochverrat oder Gefährdung des demokratischen Rechtsstaats.
Friedensverrat vielleicht kurz erklären, das ist sowas wie Habeeiführung eines Angriffskrieges.
Ja, genau. Also dann hätte der Staatsschutz aber zu viel zu tun.
Ja, wenn sie das machen würden, dann müssten sie ja den Herrn Joschka Fischer verhaften und die SPD-Führung, das geht ja nicht.
Nee, deswegen kümmern sich dann lieber um die unechten politischen Straftaten, also sprich solche Sachen wie Autos anzünden, denen ein politischer Kontext vermutet wird. Was ja auch übrigens sehr lustig ist, in Berlin haben sie ja im Zuge dieser ganzen Autoabfackelungen haben sie auch eigentlich immer routinemäßig den Startschutz eingeschaltet, bis die offensichtlich, also sie kamen nur aus den Pressemitteilungen folgern, offensichtlich die Schnauze voll davon hatten und gesagt haben sie, naja, sowieso eine 80% Versicherungsbetrug bei diesen ganzen Autoabfackelungen. Ja, naja. Gut, dann sind wir damit so weit am Ende. Wir sind jetzt übrigens bei einer Stunde 30. Wollen wir jetzt echt noch die Netzneutralität hinterher machen?
Na, haben wir angekündigt, oder?
Na ja, wir könnten am Anfang nochmal neu entsprechen.
Die längste Sendung aller Zeiten.
Wollen wir eine zweite so lange losmachen? Ja, Netzneutralität. Was ist denn eigentlich Netzneutralität?
Das ist das Problem. Da hat eigentlich jeder Subtil andere Vorstellung von, was denn das jetzt konkret ist. Und wir haben uns gedacht, wir fangen mal an, indem wir ein bisschen erklären, wie das eigentlich mit dem Internet funktioniert.
Erklär doch mal, wie das Internet funktioniert. Das wollte ich eigentlich schon seit mindestens 15 Jahren wissen. Wie funktioniert dieses Internet eigentlich?
Ja, das Internet ist eigentlich nur ein Zusammenschluss von Rechnern und zwar ursprünglich nicht hierarchisch organisiert, sondern das waren einfach ein paar US-Unis und Militärinstallationen, die da zusammengeschaltet wurden. Der Gründungsmythos, da gibt es eine ganz lustige Anekdote zu, die ich jetzt leider hier nicht wieder gefunden habe, aber es gibt also die Geschichte, dass die Bedarfsträger damals, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche US-Behörde, wollte eben die Unis schon überwacht haben, beziehungsweise sich da immer eingeloggt haben jeweils und hatte aber keine Lust, aus Virginia dann jeweils ein langes Kabel einmal durchs Land zu ziehen, zu jeder Uni in Kalifornien separat, weil damals hat man eben noch Standleitungen benutzt. Und das war quasi die Idee, warum man jetzt nicht über dieselbe Leitung ein bisschen multiplexen kann. Aber ursprünglich ist das nicht hierarchisch. Und jeder, der Hardware hatte, um sich ans Netz anzuklemmen, das waren eigentlich auch Modems, genau wie man heute Modems nimmt, nur spricht man eben paketverbundene Sachen darüber und nicht einfach nur eine Leitung, wo genau ein Mensch mit genau einer Gegenseite redet.
Die ersten Leitungen waren noch so richtig Modem-Leitungen?
Die ersten Leitungen waren noch so richtig Modem und zwar wie bei BBSen, also auch nicht deutlich schneller. Das waren halt so Unix-Terminals, die man damals angebunden hat. Serial, das hat richtig Sinn gemacht, auch dann Modems zu nehmen. Und die Idee, dass man das Paket vermittelt macht und nicht Circuit-Switched wie beim Telefon, dass man eine richtige Verbindung aufbaut, das ist das Alleinstellungsmerkmal vom Internet gegenüber den alternativen Medien, die es damals gab. So, die Idee, dass wenn ich eine Netzzugangshardware habe, dass ich mich einfach ans Netz anklemme, das nennt man Peering.
Ist das so wie Our All Friends hier modell?
Genau, das ist wie wenn wir im Hackcenter beim Kongress einfach ein paar Switches hinstellen und wer kommt und ein Notebook hat oder was weiß ich mit seinem Rechner, das sieht man heute weniger häufig als früher, aber wenn jemand kommt und sich mit seiner Hardware einfach anklemmen will, dann kann er das tun.
Du warst doch auch noch so ein Rechner durch die Gegend.
Ich war auch noch so ein Rechner durch die Gegend, genau. Portable hieß die Klasse.
Portable?
Auf der Schulter.
Ich kann mich erinnern, wir waren mal, irgendwo sind wir dann da hingefahren. Ich weiß nicht, meinetwas, kam ich am Flughafen an und du standest...
Portugal war das, ne?
Portugal, genau.
Das ist auch noch eine Anekdote, die wir nochmal erzählen müssen. Das war der Brüller.
Du kamst am Flughafen an und hattest...
Ich kam mit meinem Portable auf der Schulter.
Dein Mini-Tower auf der Schulter. Ich hatte glaube ich, das letzte Klärlob.
Wir hatten noch eine Sun dabei, die war auch noch relativ...
Stimmt, wir hatten noch eine Sun dabei, ja. Nee, die Sun hatten die da. Die Sun hatten die da. Genau, da gab es kein Keyboard für die doofes Sun.
Lass uns doch gleich nochmal das Problem erzählen. Das war nämlich superwitzig. Eigentlich waren wir eingeladen, um ein Lifehack zu machen, was eigentlich heute, würden wir das nie mehr machen, weil das total unseriös ist. Aber das war, waren wir das, in den 90er Jahren?
1994, 1995.
Das war richtig doll früh. Und damals waren wir quasi allein auf weiter Flur. Und das war noch nicht so eine Showveranstaltung wie heute. Und es ging darum, den Leuten im Land, also es war nicht für jedermann offen, sondern das war uns vorher nicht wirklich erklärt, wer das war. Das war ein Teil der Anekdote, dass wir vorher im Grunde nicht wussten, wer da sitzt. Die haben gesagt, ja ja, wichtige Leute. Und wir haben gedacht, naja, gut, wenn es wichtige Leute sind, nehmen wir mal dahin. Und dann sind wir dahin gegangen und haben aufgebaut. Und was ich also zeigen wollte damals, ich hab auf der Sun dann so einen Webserver gestartet und dann haben wir dann eine Firewall installiert und die hat nur Port 80 durchgelassen. Und die Demo sollte zeigen, dass man, obwohl da eine Firewall ist, wenn der Port 80 unsicher Software fährt, dass man eben trotzdem da die Sun übernehmen kann.
Also nicht so verschieden von dem heute.
Genau, genau wie heute ist eine Einsicht, die immer noch bei nicht allen Leuten angekommen ist. Aber wir haben also diese Demo gemacht und wie das so ist bei Vorführungen, es klappte nicht auf Anhieb und Du musstest auf der Bühne Ich musste auf der Bühne, musste ich dann noch irgendwie Sachen fummeln und dann Du hast doch, warte mal, du hast doch noch den Webserver cross-compiled auf der Bühne. Wir wussten halt nicht, was die da haben. Wir haben gedacht, die haben einen PC und haben die dann eine Spark gehabt. Wie das so ist, bei Sun war damals kein Compiler dabei und es war zum Kotzen. Dann habe ich da mit einem Cross-Compiler schnell das kaputte Binary erzeugt, was ich dann da exploiten wollte und es war alles furchtbar. Jedenfalls, es klappte nicht auf Anhieb und selbst, als wir es dann rüber kopiert hatten, hatten wir da so ein Setup gemacht, das auf der Sun war irgendwie ein X-offen mit einem Webbrowser. Der hat auf dem Webserver irgendwie eine Seite gehabt und die hat immer per JavaScript sich selbst reloadet, einmal pro Sekunde. Dann habe ich quasi die Datei editiert in meinem Exploit damit, also sich die Hintergrundfarbe änderte, damit man es aus dem Publikum sehen konnte, dass ich da was eingegriffen habe. Und das funktionierte nicht auf Anhieb, weil das war halt irgendwie fummelig mit den Offsets damals schon. Und dann fing ich also an, so ein bisschen hektischer zu werden und tippte dann mal schneller.
Ich saß im Publikum hinter den Typen, die wir später als irgendein hohes Tier in irgendeinem Geheimdienst und dem Chef der Commuterkriminalität der dortigen Krümlerkriminalität.
Also ich wusste nicht mehr, wer das ist. Das waren lauter distinguierter ältere Geherrschaften in Anzügen.
Ja, schlecht sitzende Anzüge.
Und ich tippte halt immer schneller. Und der Typ, der uns da eingeladen hatte, wurde auch langsam nervös und meinte, wir machen jetzt mal Pause und so. Und ich so, ne ne, das schaff ich schon noch. Da war ich halt an der Ehre gepackt. Und dann hat es auch tatsächlich noch geklappt.
Ja, Fefe hat es tatsächlich geschafft. Und ich saß halt hinter diesen Typen.
Und dann haben wir trotzdem Pause gemacht, weil er es halt angesagt hatte. Und dann hielten die alle so 10 Meter Abstand von mir. In der Pause. Also richtig spürbar. Sie wichen so zurück, wenn ich mir nicht so glücklich ging, um mir da was zu trinken zu holen.
Und Fefe konnte sich das nicht so richtig erklären.
Und ich sag so, was denn hier los, ja? Und dann haben wir halt den Typen mal gefragt, wer das denn jetzt eigentlich ist. Und er meinte so, ach, weißt du, wir haben letzte Woche, hat die Konkurrenz auch so was machen wollen, so ein Live-Hacking und die sind alle am Flughafen verhaftet worden. Weil das war halt so die Zeit damals noch. Hacker waren böse und gefährlich und haben mit dem KGB zusammen gearbeitet.
Und der Hammer war dann noch hier, saß er hinter diesem Geheimdiensttypen und dem Kriminalpolizisten. Und der eine raunte dem anderen so, look how fast he is typing. This guy is dangerous.
Also das hat mich halt alles nicht mitgekriegt aus der Vorführung vorne. Aber der Typ erzählte uns dann so ganz locker, ja, die letzte Woche sind alle verhaftet worden und deswegen habe ich die Polizei eingeladen. Der Typ da, das ist der Security-Chef der einen telco. Das da links ist der Security-Chef vom Parlament. Und der da macht die telco 1, der macht die telco 2. Das ist der Polizei-Chef und das ist hier die Cyber-Warfare-Abteilung des Militärs. Und ich saß da nur so gulp. Also das war echt eine großartige.
Aber wir hatten noch eine schöne Stadtführung von dem Security-Chef von der einen telco. Die war auch richtig nett.
Also es waren nette Leute, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Aber wenn ich vorher gewusst hätte, dass die Vorgänger vorher verhaftet worden waren, dann wäre ich glaube ich weniger entspannt gewesen.
Tja, was man so macht in der Jugend. Aber zurück zur Netzneutralität.
Also damals gab es Peering, heute gibt es immer noch Peering. Heute ist das so. Es gibt dann natürlich gewisse Sachzwänge, wie die Interkontinental-Leitung zwischen Deutschland und Europa. Da gibt es natürlich viele von. Aber ich sag erst mal, die Leitung ist natürlich teurer als die Leitung von mir zu Hause zu dem Pop oder der nächsten Uni, wo ich mich halt anklemmen würde, dem ISP. Daher braucht man da natürlich Finanzierungsstrukturen, die das tragen können. Und da gab es eben die Idee, am Anfang zahlt das alles die Forschungsgemeinschaft. Das waren halt Unis oder das Militär. Da zahlt es eben das Militär. Aber wenn man sowas dann privatwirtschaftlich macht, da haben sich dann eben so Modelle ergeben, wie das sich jemand findet. Quasi eine Betreibergesellschaft, die einfach ein langes Kabel unterm Ozean legt und die sich das dann eben gegenfinanziert, dadurch, dass sie von den Leuten Geld haben will, die das benutzen. Und so ergibt sich dann schon so eine Art Sternenstruktur. Aber das ist nicht inhärent. Also man könnte das auch ohne machen. Und es gibt inzwischen so viele Leitungen unterm Ozean, auch zwischen anderen Kontinenten. Es gibt eine Leitung nach Asien natürlich auch, nicht nur nach Amerika.
Früher waren es Satellitenleitungen.
Ganz früher, genau. Satelliten gibt es immer noch. Aber da ist die Latenz deutlich höher, deswegen macht man es weniger. Aber das ist keine inhärent sternförmige Sache, sondern im Grunde kann sich jeder mit jemand anderem zusammenklemmen und da spricht auch nicht viel dagegen, außer dass eben manche Leute dann Ansprüche entwickelt haben. Ich bin jetzt hier nicht nur ein ISP, ich bin ein Carrier. Ich habe hier mehr Leitungen als alle anderen und ich habe so viele Leitungen, dass ich Geld von anderen dafür nehmen kann, dass sie Zugriff zu meinem Leitungsnetz kriegen. Diese Idee ist dann irgendwann entstanden. Das nennt man dann nicht Peering, sondern das nennt man Transitgebühren, die man zahlen muss, um da angeschrieben zu werden.
Die Leute, die auf diese Ideen gekommen sind, sind ausschließlich die alten Telefongesellschaften. Also von den neuen ISPs ist soweit ich weiß keiner, der zumindest vor den großen Privatisierungsrunden auf diese Idee gekommen ist.
Im Grunde ist es Wilder Westen gewesen. Und irgendwann sind die telcos gekommen und haben gesagt, wie, da nimmt man kein Geld für. Die haben halt den dicken Drog vor sich gehabt, wo sie halt überhaupt richtig reingegriffen haben. Und das war denen nicht begreiflich zum Ahnen, dass man da kein Geld für nimmt. Tja, und so gibt es eben heute so eine Art mehr Tier, das nennt man das Struktur, aus verschiedenen. Oben sind halt die Carrier, darunter sind dann die regionalen ISPs und ganz unten bin halt ich kleiner Benutzer. Und ich kann zwar auch peeren mit WLAN mit meinem Nachbarn, aber das sind eben noch keine Routbandeinheiten, die da gepieert werden, sondern das ist einfach nur privat gefummelt. Aber von der Struktur ist alles dasselbe. Es gibt also keinem, dem das Internet gehört. Man zahlt die Leitung gemeinsam. Es gibt auch, also nicht nur Leitungen sind teuer, sondern es gibt auch so was wie einen großen Switch, wo sich jeder ranklemmen darf. Und so was nennt sich Internet-Exchange. Und da gibt es mehrere von.
Meistens sind diese Internet-Exchanges an den Endpunkten von den großen Transkontinentalleitungen, also sowas wie Amsterdam und so. Da sind die ganz großen, Frankfurt und Deutschland, weil da die ganz internationalen Leitungen ankommen. Aber es gibt dann halt auch regionale Internet-Exchanges, die...
Also es gibt zum Beispiel zwei in Berlin.
Ja, also und die sind halt häufig so organisiert, dass da die Internet-Anbieter sich halt einfach zusammenschließen. Also die regionalen meistens, um halt den Verkehr zwischen ihren Kunden kostenneutral auszutauschen. Also die Leute, die halt dann einfach einen Port an den Inter-Exchange buchen, stecken da halt ihren Netz-Treffik rein und alle Server, die bei ihnen stehen, können von allen anderen zugegriffen werden. Und umgekehrt alle Kunden, die bei ihnen klicken, können auf die Server im Netz zugreifen.
Das hat sich natürlich ein bisschen professionellisiert über die Jahre. Also inzwischen will man nicht nur einen Switch, sondern man will, dass der Ausfall sicher ist. Und da gibt es dann halt eine Firma, die mietet sich da ein paar Räume an und hat da eine ausfallsich Stromversorgung und eine Klimaanlage und bla. Und da kann man dann normalerweise auch gleich in der Nähe hosten. Also das fließt alles so ein bisschen ineinander über. Aber im Grunde ist es so, dass jeder, der Bock hat, kann sich zu diesem Switch gehen da anklemmen lassen, zahlt dann halt anteilig ein bisschen die Miete mit. Also richtig Profit macht da eigentlich kaum jemand mit. Na klar, die werden schon Geld daraus tragen, aber das ist doch so, dass die da keine Wegelagereien wie irgendwie die telcos da abziehen. Ohne jetzt jemanden bei Namen nennen zu wollen.
Also die telcos haben da natürlich eine andere Vorstellung von, nämlich bei ihnen sind halt viele Kunden, also nehmen wir mal eine große deutsche magentafarbende telco, die in Deutschland halt die meisten Internetnutzer anbindet. Und die haben dann halt die Vorstellung zu sagen, also bei uns sind jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in Millionen Leute, die halt hier DSL haben oder über Kabel angeschlossen sind. Und wer mit diesen Kunden kommunizieren möchte, also zu diesen Kunden eine gute Serveranbindung haben möchte, der muss entweder so groß sein, dass er selber ein Carrier ist, also ein Telekom-Provider, ein Großer mit selber mehreren Millionen Kunden, oder er muss dafür zahlen.
Nun ist es so, dass die großen Anbieter normalerweise relativ teuer sind oder Hosting gar nicht selber anbieten, sondern wenn die Hosting anbieten, dann ist es gleich irgendwie so dem Atombunker. Also die haben dann auch...
Nicht mal. Teilweise ist es auch schrottig, sie nehmen nur Preise wie Atombunker.
Genau, sie nehmen halt Preise wie Atombunker. Das heißt, üblicherweise, wenn jemand privat seinen Rechner irgendwo hosten lassen will, so für 50 Euro im Monat oder was, die Größenordnung oder gar Virtual-Hosting, das sind irgendwie so 10 Euro im Monat, das ist nicht bei nateco, sondern das ist ein Drittanbieter. Und die Telekom macht dann halt so eine Art Schutzgeldnummer und geht dahin und sagt, oh, schönen Server haben sie da, das wäre ja schade, wenn den keiner erreicht. Weil wir nur so einen kleinen Strohhalm als Leitung haben und wollen sie uns nicht Geld geben, dafür, dass sie besser angebunden sind. Das heißt, hier wird künstlich eine Knappheit geschaffen, um daraus Profit zu schlagen. Und das ist im Grunde das Kernproblem, was die Netzneutralitätsdebatte vermeiden möchte.
Ja, also die Telkos sagen halt, dass es eine Knappheit im Netz gibt und diese Knappheit muss man dadurch beheben, dass man bestimmte Artenverkehr im Internet beschränkt oder reguliert oder drosselt und andere dafür bevorzugt. Ein klassisches Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel immer Internettelefoniere. Sie sagen halt so, wir müssen halt eingreifen, weil sonst könnte halt niemand mehr telefonieren, weil das ganze Netz mit Bitterand voll wäre.
Also was wir als Insta in der Stelle mal sagen können, Bullshit. Das stimmt nur sehr bedingt.
Ja, also es stimmt halt irgendwie in bestimmten Netzkomponenten nämlich da, wo es halt zum Endbenutzer geht, also die sozusagen der Außenteilsnetz ist, aber in den ganzen Backbones, das ist halt Unsinn, weil da ist halt genügend Kapazität vorhanden. Es gibt halt Außenteilnetz, zum Beispiel Kabelnetz-Provider, bei denen ist halt einfach das Kabel zum Kunden halt das Problem, weil du hast halt einfach nur, keine Ahnung, 100 Megabit, die sich halt 500 Kunden oder so teilen.
Nein, nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Also ich hab mich mal mit so jemandem unterhalten von der Weile und der meinte so was wie, na, pro Transponder haben wir irgendwie so 50 MBit. Und wie viel Transponder haben sie denn? Neuer im Moment so drei. Aber wir hätten irgendwie, wenn wir wollten. Also das ist nicht so, dass es da ein physisches Limit gibt.
Also die haben einfach nur nicht ausgebaut oder?
Die haben einfach, nö, warum soll man da mehr Transponder zuweisen, als man braucht?
Naja, kostet halt auch jedes Mal Geld in den Kabelkopfstationen.
Ja, also das ist kein physisches Limit.
Okay, aber es ist zumindest ein Limit, der ins Netzwerk...
Aber man kann sich das natürlich überlegen. Kabel Deutschland bietet jetzt 100 MBit Internet an. Und wenn man da irgendwie eine Million Leute mit anbindet, dann kann man sich überlegen, so eine dicke Leitung gibt es nicht nach außen, dass die alle mit voller Bandbreite machen können. Also es ist nicht ganz von Hand zu weisen, so ein bisschen knapp existiert. In der Praxis ist die aber nicht da. Also wenn man sich die Statistiken anguckt, sowohl an den Backbones als auch an den internationalen Leitungen zwischen Europa, da ist noch mehr als genug Bandbreite da. Also meine Statistiken sind ein paar Jahre alt, aber da waren so unter 5 % Auslastung.
Also vielleicht sind es jetzt 10 oder 12 oder so?
Genau, also da ist nicht von auszugehen, dass da in irgendeiner Weise ein Limit erreicht ist. Sogar DZX, also der große Internet-Exchange in Deutschland, in Frankfurt, sogar die haben jetzt bei der Netznotaritätsanhörung im Bundestag verkündet, nein, sie hätten dann noch deutlich Luft.
Ja, und die Telekom konnte lustigerweise auch bei der Enquet-Kommission nicht benennen, wo jetzt eigentlich der Engpass ist, der eine Regulierung, also ein Zulassen von, ja.
Das ist ja deren Argument. Also die haben argumentiert, ja, wir haben hier Engpässe. Und dann kam die Frage, ja, wo denn? Und dann so, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Ein dreiköpfiger Affe.
Genau. Cricket-Geräusche mit der Grundsache, ein Double-Beat rollt vorbei. Ja, das war das. Die konnten es halt nicht benennen. Es gibt einfach keine. Das ist im Grunde ist es eine Lüge. Aber es ist eben profitabel, wenn die eine künstliche Knappheit herbeiführen und dann quasi Premium-Internet verkaufen.
Naja, also.
Das heißt, man kann Profit damit machen, wenn man anfängt, da Quality-of-Service einzuführen und sagt, naja, die Leute, die hier irgendwie zehn Euro für eine Flatrate zahlen, die kriegen dann halt da ranz Internet. Das ist ja im Grunde die Aussage. Und wenn du aber Voice-over-IP willst oder bei der Telekom, das ist ja nicht nur das, sondern die verkaufen ja diese Triple-Pay-Dinger, das heißt Triple-Play, freudscher Versprecher. Und da kriegt man dann eben auch Fernsehen über Internet. Und da ist natürlich, das wäre unangenehm, wenn irgendwie dem Nachbarn sein Premiere ruckelt.
Wenn der Porn ruckelt, weil du gerade deinen Porn über Torot ziehst.
Weil ich gerade Torot mache, genau, das wäre unangenehm. Und das ist im Grunde, wovor die Telekom Angst hat, gar nicht mal vor der Telefonie, weil das so einen verschwindend geringen Anteil am Netz ausmacht. Das ist nicht das wirkliche Szenario. Aber das Fernsehen wäre halt doof, wenn die Telekom nicht das Fernsehen priorisieren dürfte.
Ja, na ja, das ist halt die Frage, was ist dann halt eine vernünftige Position an dieser Diskussion?
Und das ist halt sehr schwierig, denn die Positionen gehen deutlich auseinander.
Also, wir müssen vielleicht noch mal erklären, was sozusagen unser Worst-Case-Szenario ist, warum wir uns überhaupt mit diesem ganzen Thema Netzneutralität beschäftigen. Und das Worst-Case-Szenario ist, dass bestimmte Inhalte beschränkt werden. Also bestimmte Inhalte, wie zum Beispiel dieser Podcast. Jetzt will ich aus der Luft gegriffen. Nehmen wir an, wir machen das als CDL-Überdach und sind irgendwie alte Dradikal geworden. Und es gibt halt keine Netzneutralität. Das heißt also, nehmen wir an, es käme so weit, dass Internet-Service-Provider den Zugang zu bestimmten Inhalten nach Lust und Laune beschränken können und die Technologie dafür aufbauen, um es zu tun. Dann kommen natürlich auch die ganzen Begehrlichkeiten dazu, wie wir für den inhaltlichen Zensur, wie wir es jetzt bei der Kinderpornografie-Debatte auch diskutiert haben. Aber der Kern dabei ist halt, wenn man anfängt, dafür zu bezahlen, dass Inhalte bevorzugt ausgeliefert werden, dann heißt es, dass automatisch andere Inhalte benachteiligt werden. Und wenn wir, keine Ahnung, was haben wir jetzt?
Also nicht zwingend, aber das müssen sie dann tun, um das verkaufen zu können.
Genau.
Wir haben ja gerade gesagt, also eigentlich gibt es keine Knappheit, aber wenn sie Geld dafür haben wollen, das was mit Priorität geliefert wird, dann müssen sie das für die anderen schlechter machen. Also das ist derselbe Grund, warum die zweite Klasse im Flugzeug so wenig Beinfreiheit hat. Das ist ja kein Zwang, sondern das machen die damit so einen Leidensdruck hast, die erste Klasse zu buchen.
Ist denn halt so die Aussage lautet dann halt von dem Luigi, von dem talco lautet, ah, schönen Content haben sie da. Wär doch schade, wenn er so langsam zum User kommt.
Das haben sie mit YouTube gemacht. Also das ist kein theoretisches Szenario, sondern US-Provider haben gesagt, hey Google, du hast aber einen schönen Videoserver da. Das wäre doch schade, wenn das ruckelt. Und dann hat Google gesagt, naja, dann bauen wir halt ein Rechenzentrum in der Nähe der User. Und da haben die ISPs gesagt, ja, aber wir können das ja immer noch ruckeln lassen. Und genau das passiert. Also wenn man, in Deutschland war ich als persönlich jahrelang Telekom-Grunde und YouTube hat geruckelt und ich dachte, das muss ruckeln in Europa. Ja, das stimmt einfach überhaupt nicht. Das ist inzwischen wohl auch bei der Telekom partiell besser geworden, aber wenn ich hier von meinem Kabelanschluss zu Hause Google pinge, dann habe ich da eine Latenz, die ist genauso groß wie wenn ich die interne Infrastruktur meines Providers pinge. Also das gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, warum das da irgendwas ruckeln sollte oder langsam wäre. Das ist künstlicher beigeführt. Und wenn YouTube sich von so was erpressen lässt, das öffnet natürlich die Fluttore, weil dann kommt als nächstes die New York Times. Das geht ja gar nicht darum, dass man wirklich viel Inhalt hat, sondern die können ja...
Kann halt einfach nur ein bisschen scheißerer sein.
Ja, das ist kein einfach... Ach, wissen Sie, das wäre ja doof, wenn Ihre Werbung nicht kommt. Wenn die Leute alle schon weitergeklickt haben, bevor Ihre Werbung geladen hat.
Oder die Webseite nicht lädt, weil die Werbung nicht lädt. Wie es ja heutzutage immer wieder der Fall ist.
Ja gut, aber da kann die Times ja was gegen tun. Aber jeder ist quasi erpressbar damit, wenn man sagt, also wissen Sie, wenn Ihre Seite zu langsam lädt, dann gehen die User weg. Und da gibt es Statistiken drüber, das ist tatsächlich nachweisbar. Wenn das zu langsam ist, dann haben die User keinen Bock und gehen weg.
Ja, stimmt. Und zwar machen da wenige Dutzend Millisekunden schon Unterschied.
Das stimmt einfach tatsächlich und das ist ein valides Argument, warum Content-Anbieter dann eben sagen, na ja, dann zahlen wir halt. Und das ist ein Flutor, was wir nicht öffnen wollen. Und wir glauben, also das ist jetzt nicht, dass wir Leute wie die Telekom schlecht machen wollen, sondern deren Pflicht als Aktiengesellschaft ist, für die Aktionäre Profit zu machen. Und das ist ein valider Weg, Profit zu machen. Und da können wir denen nicht böse sein, wenn sie das tun wollen. Weil das ist das Aktiengesetz. Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt über Regulierung dafür sorgen, dass das keine Option ist für die. Die können gern anders Geld verdienen, aber nicht so.
Der Punkt ist, es scheint dir so ein paar kleine Bereiche zu geben, wo man sagt, es gibt da möglicherweise technische Notwendigkeiten. Also bitte hören zum Beispiel, neigt halt einfach dazu, macht halt jeden Kanal voll, den gegriffen bekommt.
Das haben sie ja schon gefixt. Das haben sie schon gefixt, indem sie den ausgehenden Teil, wir haben ja asymmetrische Bandbreite. Wir haben dicke Bandbreite incoming und fast gar keine Bandbreite outgoing. Ich habe so einen Kabel-Deutschland-Zugang zu Hause und wenn du mal ausrechnest, wie viel Traffic du brauchst, wenn du mit voller Bandbreite ziehen willst, nur für die ausgehenden Acknowledgement-Pakete. Das füllt genau die Bandbreite, die sie dir zur Verfügung stellen ausgehend. Das heißt, die haben das genau so gemacht, dass Torrent keinen Spaß macht, absichtlich. Du wirst nie mit BitTorrent, also wenn du es tatsächlich im Peer-to-Peer-Modus benutzt, dass du auch rausgehend in Traffic hast, wirst du nie die volle Bandbreite haben. Und das machen alle Provider so. Da gibt es keinen technischen Grund für, sondern das machen die nur dazu, damit Torrent ihnen nicht das Netz zuschwimmt.
Ja, also gut, aber wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen weiter. Es gibt halt irgendwie, in wenigen Jahren wird Telefonie-Vorstellung nicht IP-basiert sein. Also auch das war das bei ISDN, als ISDN bei dir aus der Wand kommt.
Ja, es ist im Grunde schon weitgehend so.
Ist dann nur noch ein IP. Und da gibt es halt solche Services wie Notruf oder so was oder Telemedizin oder so. Die, wo man irgendwie zumindest annehmen könnte, dass es eine technische Berechtigung geben könnte zu sagen, da will ich sicher sein, garantiert haben, dass die ankommen. Das ist halt diese Quality of Service-Garantie. Der Problempunkt dabei ist aber, dass eben genau dadurch, dass dieses Quality of Service so problematisch sein kann, wenn es halt eben verwendet wird, um andere Services auszusperren. Und man sagt, ja, hier ist leider keine Bandbreite mehr übrig für Alternativlose, weil irgendwie wir haben schon alles mit Quality of Service-Zusagen für irgendwie YouPorn, irgendwie den Telefon und Premiere zu gemacht. Und tut uns leid, dass irgendwie dein schöner Podcast so langsam lädt, aber du könntest ja auch dafür bezahlen. Um dieses Szenario zu verhindern, Bedarf ist dann eigentlich eine Regulierung von solchen Quality of Service-Ansätzen. Das heißt also, wenn tatsächlich ein telco sagt, er möchte gerne Quality of Service anbieten für bestimmte Funktionen, bestimmte Netzfunktionen, Telefonie, dergleichen Dinge mehr, dann müsste es eigentlich nach meinem Verständnis so sein, dass die regulierungspflichtig sind. Also dass die nur zugelassen werden, wenn es nicht um reinen Profit geht, sondern tatsächlich um gesellschaftsnotwendige Funktionen wie zum Beispiel Notruf.
Das ist auch genau das Problem, dass im Grunde sich alle einig sind, was wir vermeiden wollen, nämlich dass die Telekom uns erpressen kann oder also jetzt die Telekom stellvertretend, dass wir erpressbar dadurch sind, dass unser Traffic irgendwie nicht beachteiligt wird. Aber woran macht man es jetzt fest? Und da gab es verschiedene Ansätze. Und einer war, dass man generell sagt, Quality of Service ist verboten. Und das ist nicht zielführend. Das liegt einfach daran, ohne Quality of Service macht Internet keinen Spaß. Das kann jeder bei sich zu Hause testen. Wenn ihr mehr als einen im Netz habt und der eine macht einen Upload und der andere macht einen Download, dann kommt von dem Download nichts mehr durch. Wenn es doch durchkommt, dann hat euer Router Quality of Service. Und das ist heute ein Standardfeature in DSL-Routern. Das macht man einfach so, weil es ohne keinen Spaß macht. Und das ist eine Sache, das ist auch im Grunde nicht verhandelbar. Also jetzt zu sagen, wir wollen kein Quality of Service mehr, dann geht so viel plötzlich nicht mehr, das will man nicht. Und Quality of Service sieht üblicherweise so aus, dass der Router oder die ISPs gucken sich eben die Pakete an und sagen, okay, dieser Verkehr, das ist also eine übliche Heuristik an der Stelle, ist, dass man sagt, wenn das Paket klein ist, ist es wichtig, dann ist es ein interaktiver Dienst. Da merkt man ruckeln, zum Beispiel Voice-over-IP hat viele kleine Pakete. Eine HTTP-Download hat auch viele Pakete, aber die sind alle groß. Also das ist so eine Heuristik, auf die man guckt. Oder dass man sagt, das ist web, das machen wir jetzt in eine tiefere Kategorie, also weniger priorisiert als zum Beispiel SSH-Fernwartung. Also man guckt sich an, welcher Dienst das gerade ist. Das ist natürlich nicht immer beantwortbar. Wenn jetzt jemand einen VPN benutzt, zum Beispiel, kann man da nicht reingucken. Aber im Großen und Ganzen macht man so Sachen wie, bei E-Mail ist es nicht so wichtig, dass es sofort ankommt, wie bei Jabba, also irgendwie Instant Messaging zum Beispiel. Ja, solche, diese Arten von Diensten kann man üblicherweise durch drauf gucken, auf die Pakete auseinanderhalten.
Und wie tief musst du dazu reingucken in die Pakete?
Das ist halt, das hängt davon ab. Also üblicherweise reicht es, wenn man auf den Port guckt bei TCP, für so eine grobe Analyse. Und viel mehr will man eigentlich auch nicht machen im Router, weil das natürlich auch Aufwand ist. Ja, und der Router soll eigentlich routen und nicht die Pakete analysieren. Daher, also das Quality of Service, was man so üblicherweise findet, den meisten Aufwand treibt noch so der plaste Router bei dir zu Hause. Aber so was die ISPs machen im Moment, also das Stichwort an der Stelle heißt eben Deep Packet Inspection, DPI, da geht es eben darum, in die Pakete rein zu gucken. Und da, wo man jetzt die Schranke setzt und sagt, das ist jetzt tief in die Pakete reingucken, das ist eben auch strittig. Aber so die Internetprotokolle sind wie so eine Zwiebel, da gibt es eben auch eine IP, da steht nur die IP-Adresse. Und das reicht eben nicht, um zu sagen, welcher Dienst das ist, sondern da muss man in das Paket ein bisschen tiefer reingucken und dann stellt man fest, das ist jetzt ein TCP-Paket, das ist verbindungsorientiert, wie zum Beispiel Web oder E-Mail. Und da guckt man dann auf den Port und der Port ist sagen wir 25. Und damit kann man wissen, das ist E-Mail. Ja, also man guckt schon so ein bisschen in die Pakete rein. Aber sobald jemand zu tunneln anfängt oder einen VPN betreibt, kann man das halt vergessen.
Der Punkt ist natürlich in dem Augenblick, wo du halt so tief in die Pakete reingucken kannst, also die technischen Möglichkeiten.
Da geht natürlich noch viel mehr, na klar.
Also die Maschinen, die sie da so hinstellen, also zum Beispiel hört diese Service Control Engines, so heißt es bei cisco, die können halt zum Beispiel auch einzelne Protokolle blockieren. Also die können zum Beispiel technisch durchaus alle IP-Adressen, die für Tor-Server da sind, also Tor-Animisierungsdienst blockieren, wenn die Liste entsprechend frisch ist.
Also man kann auch so Sachen machen, wie zum Beispiel BitTorrent nur durchlassen, wenn es im eigenen Netz ist oder so. Also die Fantasie ist da quasi die Grenze. Technisch geht da alles. Das ist auch eins der Probleme, warum Leute angefangen haben zu sagen, DPI ist böse, das müssen wir verbieten. Weil einer der Haupteinsatzzwecke für DPI sind eben so Leute wie das BKA. Wenn die deinen E-Mail-Traffic zu Hause abhören wollen, dann schalten die da einmal die Packet-Inspection an, um erstmal den Traffic zu dir zu isolieren. Das wird ja nicht bei dir und deinem DSL-Anschluss dann irgendwo in der Pampa abgegriffen, sondern das lassen die sich zentral zuspielen. Die gucken dann natürlich rein und sagen, oh, der macht hier Tor, das ist verdächtig. Oder die gucken sich das an und sagen, das ist E-Mail, das wollen wir mitlesen. Oder die gucken sich das an und sagen, der hat hier Spiegel gelesen, das interessiert uns jetzt nicht. Diese Art von Untersuchung ist eigentlich Law Enforcement oder ISPs, die eben bösartig in den Traffic eingreifen wollen. Ein Beispiel, was wir jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, ist, dass die Mobilfunkbetreiber gerne Voice-over-IP blocken. Also wenn man da einen Internetzugang sich besorgt mit seinem Telefon und darüber Volk machen will, dann drei von vier Anbietern in Deutschland blocken das dann.
Ach, die blocken das schon richtig.
Ja, also da kriegst du dann gar keine Verbindung.
Oder ganz schlecht.
Manchmal kriegst du auch eine Verbindung, aber die ist so scheiße, dass es irgendwie reicht, um dem zu sagen, okay, ich ruf dich mal an.
Also das Faszinierende war das, wie mir aus der Internet-Enquete berichtet wurde, da gab es ja gerade dieses Gespräch zu der Netzneutralität. Und einer der Betroffenen ist der Zipgate, also der größte Anbieter, glaube ich, in Deutschland für unabhängigen Was-over-IP. Und der wurde gefragt, ob sie denn mal zur Regulierungsbehörde gegangen sind, um nachzufragen, wie sie denn das jetzt finden.
Warum sie geblockt werden.
Warum sie geblockt werden. Und offensichtlich sind die nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen.
Ist ja auch abwegig, dass einem der Staat hilft. Ich meine, das ist doch der alte Treppenwitz. Ich bin von der Regierung, ich bin hier, um ihnen zu helfen. Da lachst du nebenan noch ins Gesicht und glaubst nicht, weil das kann eigentlich nur ein Steuerabzieher sein.
Also interessanter Punkt, aber klar ist halt, dass offensichtlich die Regulierung sich auf solche Felder ausdehnen muss. Ja, das geht nicht anders. Also geht halt nicht anders, dass, also wenn halt gerade Internet Service Provider anfangen, halt zu regulieren, welche Bits durch ihre Leitungen fließen dürfen, ohne dass es da irgendwie Regeln vergibt, geht halt nicht mehr. Wir brauchen halt klare Regeln und die Regeln müssen so sein, dass eben die Wettbewerbsfreiheit gewahrt bleibt. Und zwar, um es mal brutal zu formulieren, aus meiner Sicht muss ein Internet Service Provider Bits schieben. Und alles andere hat er gefälligst in andere Gesellschaften auszuladen. Es geht gar nicht, dass ein Internet Service Provider Bits priorisiert oder depriorisiert, je nachdem, ob jetzt gerade seine Service-Gesellschaft, die da Fernsehen oder Telefon drauf macht, mehr oder weniger Profit macht. Es muss halt so sein, dass da gleiche Chancen für alle gewahrt bleiben.
Das ist halt schwierig. Also die technischen Details sind immer sehr schwierig an der Stelle.
Mein Ansatz dazu ist zu sagen... Pass auf, der Staat hat eine Pflicht dazu, uns eine Mindestbandbreite zu garantieren. So sagen wir mal, wie in Finnland, ein Megabit muss halt einfach jedem Bürger zur Verfügung stehen, egal wie die angeliefert werden, ob jetzt über DSL oder Kabel oder Funk oder was auch immer. Und dieses Megabit, mindestens dieses Megabit, egal was darüber hinausgemacht wird, muss ungefiltert, unreguliert, unangefasst sein.
Wie teilst du denn deinem ISP mit, wenn du einen 6-Megabit-Anschluss hast? Welches das ist, was du ungefiltert haben willst?
Kannst du einfach eine zweite IP-Adresse kriegen.
Ach echt, so funktioniert es denn?
Nee, aber so könnte man es ja machen.
Na klar, also wie man es machen könnte, weiß ich auch. Also als ich das mit dem 1-Megabit gelesen hab, dachte ich, das ist eher so eine Regelung, wie jeder da für DSL haben.
Nee, in Finnland ist es tatsächlich so. Mein Vorschlag geht ja eben darüber hinaus, zu sagen, wir interpretieren dieses Recht auf eine Mindestbandbreite ebenso, dass ein Recht auf eine ungefilterte Mindestbandbreite ist. So, und wenn du halt irgendwie dann noch dein Clicky-Bunti-TV-Whatever-Netz haben kannst, dann kannst du das halt haben. Aber jeder Internetanschluss, der technisch dazu in der Lage ist, sollte mindestens dieses eine Megabit, über das man eben telefonieren, Podcast laden, was auch immer, kann und sich informieren kann, also seine Informationsfreiheit und seine Kommunikationsfreiheit wahrnehmen kann und seine Verschlüsselungsfreiheit im Übrigen, also kommunizieren über jedes Protokoll auch in verschwindelter Form, das sollte einem halt garantiert sein. Und jeder eigentlich auch keinen technischen Grund ist nicht zu tun, weil so ein Megabit tut nicht weh. Selbst wenn die Leute darüber torrenten wie Blöde, ist halt egal.
Das Problem ist eigentlich ein politisches. Das ist auch mein Kernanliegen hier, das heute zu kommunizieren. Das Problem ist kein technisches. Wenn die wollten, könnten sie jedem Breitband, also breitbandigst Internet nach Hause legen. Die Backbones dafür gibt es. Oder wenn nicht, kann man sie bauen. Und die kriegen ja pro neuem Subscriber, kriegen die ja Geld. Für jeden Kunden kriegen die Geld. Und das Problem ist einfach, dass bei uns der Marktdruck dazu gesorgt hat, dass die alle versuchen, die Kosten zu externisieren, wo es geht. Also man sieht zum Beispiel bei der Telekom, die hat halt ihren Opalausbau, hat sie sich halt von der EU und der Bundesregierung und dem Aufbau Ost-Topf finanzieren lassen. Und den VDSL-Kram, also das heißt es zwar immer, wir investieren jetzt hier, aber da sind natürlich auch irgendwelche Fördergelder beteiligt. Natürlich. Und die anderen Provider versuchen dann zu sagen, ja, aber die Telekom ist doch monopolist und wir nutzen den Netz einfach mit. Das ist natürlich auch eine Variante selbst, die Kosten zu sparen, so ein Netz aufzubauen. Also jeder ist im Grunde bemüht, möglichst viel der Kosten um woanders hinzuschieben.
Wie soll das auch gehen?
Alles, was sie investieren, ist eben in ihre eigene Einwahlinfrastruktur, aber nicht in den Backbone. Und nicht mal die Einwahlinfrastruktur wird dann vernünftig ausgelegt, sondern da kommt dann halt irgendwie so China-Plaste hin und dann haben die 100 User zusammen irgendwie ein 100 Mbit Upstream. Und das kann natürlich nicht klappen. Und das muss eben das sein, was wir hier den entweder erzwingen oder das zumindest einen starken Anreiz liefern, dass die auch ein eigenes Interesse daran entwickeln müssen, dass sie eben auch ein Teil der einkommenden Kohle investieren in ihre Infrastruktur.
Also wir haben ja in dem Club in den Forderungen zur Netzpolitik gesagt, der Nutzen des Netzes kann sich nur entfalten, wenn Neutralität garantiert ist. Konkret, kein Zugangsanbieter darf nach inhaltlichen Kriterien Einfluss auf die Verfügbarkeit, Provisierung oder Bandbreite der weitergelassenen Daten nehmen. Einflussnahme ist generell nur akzeptabel, wenn das dem Kunden gegenüber transparent ist. Teil der Vertragsbedingungen und tatsächlich ein Kapazitätsengpass besteht. Das heißt also, wenn es dazu dient, allen Kunden einen fairen Teil der bestehenden Kapazität zuteil werden zu lassen. Das ist halt der Grundsatz, den wir da mal formuliert haben.
Man sieht so ein bisschen, dass wir auch noch selber daran arbeiten. Also der erste Ansatz war zu sagen, die dürfen nicht reduzieren, nur wenn tatsächlich die Leitung knapp ist. Aber dann ist uns aufgefallen, naja, das kann man ja halbeinführen, dass die Leitung knapp ist. Dann haben wir gesagt, machen wir das vielleicht am Profit fest. Aber so richtig, das ist halt der schwierige Teil daran. Also es ist zwar das Feindbild klar, aber wenn wir jetzt sagen, der ISP darf nur Bits schieben, dann sind ihm ja auch Sachen verboten, wie den Torrent kleiner zu ranken als E-Mail. Und das fände ich schon wichtig auch, dass ISPs das tun dürfen, weil das kommt allen zugute. Was wir halt nicht wollen, ist, dass die die User gegeneinander ausspielt und daraus Profit machen können. Das darf halt nicht erlaubt sein.
Also insbesondere halt diese Fernsehgeschichte dürfte da halt irgendwie eine drastische Rolle spielen.
Also Fernsehen ist von mir aus auch erlaubt. Denn die Telekom ist ja nicht blöd und macht zu jedem User einen Unicast, sondern die haben Multicast. Also die sind ja nicht völlig verblödet. Und wenn du jetzt guckst auf die Bandbreite insgesamt, dann macht Fernsehen, weiß ich, ein paar Prozent aus. Also das ist nicht so, dass deren Bandbreite weg ist, weil sie Fernsehen anbieten. Also das ist nur so, dass die sich natürlich Sorgen machen, dass Fernsehen irgendwo ruckeln könnte, weil der daneben einen dicken Torrent anstößt. Oder, weiss nicht, Microsoft-Updates irgendwie am Patch-Tag, dass dann Fernsehen nicht geht, weil alle Leute sich die... Das sind ja valide Bedenken. Das muss man ja mal sagen, ja. Und das kann ich schon nachvollziehen, dass die Telekom das nicht will. Aber wir müssen halt dafür sorgen, dass die nicht auf die Idee kommen, künstlich Inhalte zu benachteiligen, um daraus ein Geschäftsmodell zu entwickeln. Das ist eben der Punkt. Aber es ist eben schwierig, das so zu formulieren, dass es eine gute Regelung ist, die man nicht irgendwie umgehen oder verarschen kann.
Naja, es ist halt immer das Problem, dass der Preisdruck in der Branche ist ja so dramatisch, wenn man sich anguckt, für wenige Euro man mittlerweile Internet kriegt.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal einen internationalen Vergleich geben. Also Deutschland liegt vorne mit den Niederlanden. Wir sind zu den beiden billigsten Länder weltweit, um IP zu kriegen.
Na, das ist nicht ganz richtig. Also in Asien gibt es schon noch welche, wo du deutlich mehr Bandbeute fürs Gleiche oder ein bisschen mehr Geld kriegst.
Nee, ich meinte jetzt für Hosting, nicht so viel privates Internet. Aber Hosting ist einfach mal sportbillig bei uns. Stimmt, ja. Also es gibt noch natürlich so in Korea, gibt es irgendwie 100 Mbit für jeden. Okay, also das ist natürlich staatlich finanziert.
In Schweden auch. Nicht staatlich finanziert im Übrigen.
Also es ginge, wenn man es wollte. Das haben wir auch schon gesagt.
Es gibt ja auch genügend ISPs, die zeigen, dass es geht. Also dass man halt irgendwie auch, wenn man halt nicht nur Heuschrecker als Besitzer hat, der einem irgendwie den Profit, den man hat, irgendwie wieder zur Kredithöhung abzieht, sondern eben aus den eigenen Profiten organisch wächst, dass man durchaus in der Lage ist, halt irgendwie ein ordentliches Backbone-Netz aufzubauen, was dann halt eben entsprechend auch irgendwie dimensioniert sein kann. Und eben dann hingehen zu den Usern halt eben entsprechend auch genug Bandbreite anbieten kann. Also war ich schon ein bisschen schockiert zu hören, dass man an Stockholm problemlos 100 Megabit aus der Wand bekommt für irgendwie kleines Geld.
Ja, und wenn wir das wollten, könnten wir das auch. Aber wir wollen ja nicht mal, dass alle Leute DSL haben. Sonst wäre das ja schon längst geschehen.
Ja, spannend wird noch die Sache natürlich mit dem Übergang zum mobilen Internet-Guarder LTE. Also LTE steht für Long-Term Evolution. Das war auch so landläufig als 4G bezeichnet wird, also die nächste Generation.
Wie im der neue Euphemismus. Alles noch besser. Also für UMTS sollte ja eigentlich alle Traffic-Sorgung beheben.
Also der Punkt ist halt, dass LTE besser wird. Da habe ich irgendwie arge Zweifel, weil bei UMTS ist ja noch so, also bei 3G, dass die für Telefonate halt noch Dienstekategorien vorgesehen sind im Protokoll, die halt noch so aus der alten Welt stammen, also die halt Telefonie sind, also wo du halt noch einen vermittelten Kanal hast. Und bei LTE ist halt alles IP, IP ist halt ein reines IP-Netz, mit Qualitive Service und den ganzen Dingen in die Protokolle reindesigned, wo eben auch die Telefonie halt komplett über IP geht. Also wenn du da Telefonie ist, ist es de facto ein Voice-over-IP-Telefonat mit irgendwie Extensions für Mobile und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und so wie man sich diese schrottige Technologie, die sie da gerade installieren, so anguckt, dann kann das halt irgendwie nur ganz gruselig werden. Interessant ist übrigens, weil wir gerade bei LTE sind, was die so für dreiste Preise nehmen, wenn sie denn können. Hast du dir mal angeguckt, wo der Fonds so nimmt? Die fangen jetzt gerade an, so in Brandenburg und zu den ganzen Gebieten, wo die Telekom sich zu fein ist, DSL mal aufs Dorf zu legen, in dem sie halt ein paar Zwischenverteiler hinstellt.
Ach und?
Da fangen sie jetzt halt an, mit Staatsförderung LTE-Basestationen aufzustellen, um halt die Dörfer zu versorgen. Und das dann richtig dreiste Preise, so für 5 Gigabyte, wollen sie dann gleich so 45 Taken haben und so. Richtig so.
Es gab ja schon irgendwie den Witz, dass SMS mehr kostet, also so pro Band breiter, als wenn die NASA mit dem Mond kommuniziert. So und das stimmt einfach. Natürlich, wenn du da, also die Idee...
Gibt der telco die Gelegenheit, irgendwie dein...
Die Audi, dass der Markt da irgendwie eingreift und Ausbeuterei verhindert, ist einfach mal neocode-wix-fantasie. Das hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Nee, also auf gar keinen Fall. Die, gerade wie gesagt, in Situationen, wo sie können, also wo sie halt keine Konkurrenz haben, sondern einen Quasimodipol haben, bedingt durch die technischen Voraussetzungen, da nehmen sie es dann halt irgendwie von den Lebenden so, wie sie es hören können. Gut, dann fassen wir also noch mal zusammen. Wir sind uns im Wesentlichen einig, wenn Quality-of-Service-Methoden an Shaping und sowas verwendet wird, dann dürfen die nur so minimal wie möglich in die Pakete reingucken. Es muss begründbar sein, dass man, also wir brauchen einen Regulierer, der sagt irgendwie übrigens auch, weil so eine IP muss in deinem Netz funktionieren, auch wenn du es nicht magst. Und der auch die technische Kompetenz hat, Beschwerden nachzugehen. Weil ich glaube, einer der Gründe, warum SIPG jetzt überhaupt nicht die Mühe macht, irgendwie zur Regulierungsbehörde zu gehen, ist, weil natürlich die anderen Anbieter mal sagen, ach ja, Entschuldigung, wir haben ja kleine Firewall-Miskonfigurationen, das war irgendwie nicht keine Absicht.
Naja, die Bundesnetzagentur ist auch ansonsten echt überfordert. Also ich meine, ich hab da ja auch mal Beschwerden wegen irgendwelchen 0-900-Fraud-Dingern, die wir dir zuhause anrufen. Und da kriegst du dann ein halbes Jahr später eine E-Mail, ja, wir wollten das dann mal bearbeiten. Aber die Nummer ist schon eh gesperrt. Inzwischen so, ne? Ja, das hat's ja gebracht.
Ja super. Ja, also wie diese Behörde halt irgendwie in der Lage sein soll, Qual-Tee-Of-Service in IP-Netz zu regulieren, wird halt irgendwie schwierig zu argumentieren sein.
Da ist schon die Beweisführung echt schwierig.
Insofern ist halt schwierig. Ja, also auf die Ehrlichkeit der telcos zu bauen, ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie eher vergebende Liebesmüh. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir freuen uns auf eure Kommentare. Wir freuen uns auch über eure Flatters. Und gerade zum Thema Netzentralität, denke ich mal, werden wir auf dem Kongress auch eine Menge diskutieren.
Wir freuen uns auch über sinnvolle Vorschläge, wie man es jetzt machen kann.
Genau, also wer eine coole Idee hat dazu, wie man es irgendwie sinnvoll machen könnte, sowohl für politische Regeln als auch für technische Umsetzungen. Wie gesagt, wir sind da mitten in einer Diskussion und entwickeln da Positionen und freuen uns über Input. Dann herzlichen Dank und bis bald.